Hey fuckers,
what are you doing?
I am a right now in the middle of tweeting
this out is here. I mean she already,
it's just David Show, right? You
don't have anything special? No.
People with a crafty Twitter
names or real problem. Okay.
Or the underscore. They just have to kill
that underscores shit. Like what's your,
here's her name will underscore
named David shows and being Korean is
like nature being named John Smith. Yeah.
I went to school with three. David
chose. Yeah, I knew a few. David chose,
cause I grew up doing taekwondo
and there was a lot of,
David shows a lot of Korean kids and I'm
late. I'm late to the social media game.
So when I wanted Twitter at David show,
it was already, it was, I was fucked.
So what is your Twitter? Well,
I mean they gave it to me also.
They kept it from somebody
yanked if some nuts.
Someone like whenever there's
a new social media thing,
someone just grabs it and then I
get the email, hey, you want this?
You want to buy it off me? I'm like,
no, I'll just be David Choe one.
David chose 69 I got super
lucky with Twitter. I'm lucky.
There was like one dude who had got
the Joe Rogan one, but he wasn't used.
Joe Rogan is sort of a
basic name too, right? Yeah.
There's a guy named Joe Rogan
that's a real estate agent. Right.
He's in a thing in Idaho, but
he owns Joe rogan.com. Right.
And he wanted to sell it, but it's
a bit pricey. It's a very nice guy.
He's got a legitimate claim to it. What
does he want for it? A lot of money.
Like $1 million. No, not that much money,
but enough that it was a lot. I forget.
I don't eat, I don't, you know,
I don't have a beef with the guy because
it's his website. It's his name. Right.
The idea that it's mine more
than it is his is ridiculous.
Right. He owns it. He's,
he's Joe Rogan as well, you know,
that's his name. But uh, yeah, it's,
I'm sure it's confusing.
That was cool.
I was chose to on for a while and someone
at Twitter send me an email and said,
hey, do you want, I was like, yeah,
and fuck it. I'll take it easy.
I'm blacklisted on Twitter. It used to
be so easy to get red ban on everything.
Now I can't get it on anything
and they still won't verify me.
And yet there's like a
million fake red bands.
Like there's even fake red
selling fake ride band shirts.
And what you said it used to be,
it used to be really easily get red
band on everything, like fuck whatever.
But now it's like everyone takes
my, my name, my fake name though.
And then Twitter,
there's like a million fake red banners,
even fake red band selling fake red
band shirts and Twitter won't verify me.
So it's just a hay day with my
record band name, but it's easy.
Which one is which one says red band,
which one has 100,000 fucking friends?
There's the real idiots. Like, well let's
this Twitter worse. Can I have that?
You got,
do you have to just accept that?
But I wonder why am I black listed it
on Twitter and on a whatever that other
shit. Wikipedia blacklist.
Yeah. He just don't accept you.
That means you're doing something right
to eat whatever it is is nice comp.
If you were on any other show,
if you were on a television show and uh,
and you were like one of the guest
stars on the television show,
that would be listed in Wikipedia
most likely I would imagine.
I want me to one funniest Instagrammer
by La Weekly. That's not bad, man.
I if you were on like one legit TV show,
like if you did like an episode
of standup on the tonight show,
if you did one thing then they'd probably
put you on Wiki. You could do that too.
You know, really
interesting. See you do Leno,
what material you could do on Leno and
what that experience of the last episode
of lender. That would be awesome cause
he'd be like, I don't care. And you just
freak those fucking people out. Talk
about fucking dolphins on the Leno show.
Yeah, I don't do that. Uh, anyway,
this episode of the podcast is brought
to neither by the Jay Leno show or for
any of the other David chose or
I need the other Joe Rogan's.
Much love to all of you people, uh,
were brought to you by stamps.com.
This episode is stamps.com is a,
uh,
an excellent resource for if
you have your own business.
Managing it out of your home was far
as like sending things out. If you,
if you're trying to sell things and sell
them over the internet and send them
yourself.
Most of the time when you have to do
is you have to go to the post office,
you have to wait in line and it's,
it's really annoying and they figured
out a way to make that much easier.
You can do it from your home.
You took it from you computer,
they give you a digital scale,
they tell you how to do it.
He printed up on your own printer,
you print up your postage and then the
postman comes and takes it away and
you're done.
You cut out so much of the bullshit
of going there and waiting in line and
dealing with someone who doesn't
want to weigh your dumb shit.
You could do it all yourself.
You get a free digital scale that
you should never use for illegal non
government sanctioned drugs.
If I say don't use it for that,
but if you want to find out what does a
beer way in the bottle and you weigh it,
that's legal beers,
illegal drug and so we support
that@stamps.com but don't be weighing your
mushrooms. He fucks you. Weirdos mean
something a little more accurate.
Something like really,
really accurate for that.
You don't want to be lying about
mushrooms. That could be some awful Karma.
If you were selling mushrooms and you're
under dosing people who I think about
dosing my parents all the time,
it's probably a good idea.
Don't do it through stamps.com though
it is a little old timey microphone
in the upper right hand corner.
If you click on it and
use the code word j. R.
E you get a no risk trial
plus $110 bonus offer,
including a digital scale, enough
to $55 for free postage. And,
uh,
we,
we have personal experience with this
company because that's exactly how Brian
sends out his t shirts, the t shirts
from desk squad.tv, which are all, uh,
Brian's original art.
He sends those out through stamps.com
it does it all through his office.
So it's super easy if a
knucklehead like Brian
can do it, you can too, right Brian?
All right.
Cold wars jre for the special offer.
We're also brought to you by onnit.com
that's, Oh, Anne and I t and I fucking,
I sound like a robot repeating
myself over and over again for this.
Um,
but there's no way around it.
We have some new primal bells in the
primal belts or the kettle bells that were
designed by an artist to
look like gorillas and
chimpanzees and now orangutans
and, uh, they're fucking
pat ass and they're fun to
work out with cause they're,
they're all like legit and balanced out,
but they're fun because they look like
something that might be fucking you up.
Like it's terrifying that Steven
Shubin Juniors, that dude who, uh,
did the artwork on it,
we did a bad ass job and they're a,
they're really well balanced too. That
was like super important. All there,
there are these strange shapes. We had
to make sure that we kept it balanced.
Uh, so that it doesn't change what,
what a kettle bell workout should be,
even though it looks cool.
It doesn't change it. Uh,
so check that out at [inaudible]
dot com along with all of my various
supplements,
including testosterone boosting t plus,
they would take a testosterone booster
plus it myself and ran across
the border from Tijuana to,
it was amazing. The police, the,
you want to police it and stop this.
And they looked at us and they're like,
what are you idiots doing?
They didn't even,
it was amazing.
That won't happen through t plus
David chose taking a
walk on the wild side.
He was hanging out at that place
that that church was running.
And then you remember from,
what was that movie with George Clooney?
The vampire movie.
Oh,
does till dusk till
dawn [inaudible] movies.
Harvey Keitel had a Korean son in
that movie. I was like, what the fuck?
And it was almost like two
different movies. Yeah.
It was like there was this really intense
dramatic movie with the super violent
guy and his brother, right. It, who's
trying to keep everything under control.
It was two separate movies and then
all of a sudden it's this wild,
crazy monster movie that's really fun.
Quintin Tarantino is the baddest
motherfucker of all time,
but it comes to movies like that was
a Robert Rodriguez movie, right? Yeah,
but it was, it was amazing.
Yeah. Quentin Tarantino in that.
That's one of my favorite roles
of any actor ever plant ever.
He knows how to play that creepy
murderer dudes. So fucking good.
It's like bone chilling.
When you watch that,
like you really believe anybody who says
it, Quentin, Quentin Tarantino can't act.
You need to watch him in that movie.
If you give him the right role,
that mother fucker can act as ass
off those three movies. John. Man,
he fucking creeped me out
cause I know dudes like him.
She did. Yeah, there's dudes like
that that are they your path in life,
but I'm going to go out and get a snack
and you come back and they'd just a
murdered everybody in the room.
There's a dude that I used to train
when I was a kid. I was really young.
I was like 18 and 19 and he was a hitman.
He was a Hitman for, you know,
local gangsters, Irish gangsters.
Oh yeah.
And he wound up doing time.
He wound up getting caught for it and he
used to come to my taekwondo school and
he would just like straight ask you how
you would kill somebody if you're going
to kill somebody. I
keep me. And he wanted,
he had like a crude martial
arts background. Like it
was a very big powerful guy.
But this guy,
I knew something was up.
He would ask you how you would kill
someone or you would ask him what he's
learning how to fight.
I wanted to learn, oh,
he wanted to know how to kill someone.
They want to know,
like he would just flat out ask you
who would take the black belts and like
wouldn't, what would you do if
you're going to kill somebody,
how would you kill someone?
And like, and I was like, wow,
this guy's pretty intense. And
then we find out, you know,
years later he was a fucking Hitman,
you know? So you taught him how to kill?
Not really.
I mean he already knew how to kill people
and trust me or at least knew how to
fuck you up. Right. He was just a,
he wanted to tighten up
his martial arts technique,
but it was just interesting running into
a guy like that that you know is just
not playing by the rules.
We're all playing by,
we're playing by the be nice rules.
Most of us on this planet are playing
by the be nice roles. I want to friends,
I don't want anybody to hate me. You
want friends, you're a nice person.
When we run into people were just trying
to be nice to each other for the most
part, for the most part. I'm happy now.
And then you run into a dude
is not playing that game.
You could run into a crazy person.
I went on a hike today, it's three
o'clock right now. I was like, let's,
let's go on a hike. And uh, I go
hiking with critter. The guy out there,
I don't know how we got
onto this subject matter,
but while we're walking down the thing,
we got into an argument and he's like,
fuck you,
I can rape you if I want it to right now.
Jesus Christ. I was like, who said that
to critter? The guy sitting out though,
that's uncomfortable,
you know, and I go, what'd
you just say? He's like,
I could rape you right now
cause we're hiking. He's like,
I throw you in the bushes right now.
Rip Your Legs Open. I'll fuck them.
And critter.
He can beat the shit out of anybody.
I get that and not overpowering me.
Yes, he could overpower me. But like
that's a weird thing for him. It's a weird
thing to say to a friend and also we,
so then we got into it, you
know, of course. And I'm like,
okay,
if I went to prison or even if crude is
trying to rape me in the mountains right
now,
okay physically you get me down,
I'm fighting you. You hold my legs
down, you punching me in my face,
you ripped my pants down, now you've
overpowered me, I'm still fighting you.
Whatever.
But I was like,
it takes a special kind of guy.
There's a guy that will kill you.
There's a guy that will beat the shit
out of you. But like, like Joe's, Joseph,
you're a fighter and you could probably
beat the shit out of me, but you're like,
I want to re rape Dave Cho. You're
like, I want to. Could you like even get
your Dick hard to do that I don't think
are just, yeah, you think you could Brian,
Brian could just being excited about,
cause you know,
they do that in a guy alive
that he could rape because,
because you see it in prison movies,
you're like, we need to show, you know,
it's the most embarrassing, humiliating
thing you could do to a man. Hey,
we're supposed to start some music, but
let's not just keep talking. Keep talking.
Podcast has begun. Okay ana.com fuck
yourself, whatever. And I'm like,
uh,
what?
Like that takes this kind of guy that
you're talking about the Hitman Kinda guy.
Cause he's a little bit more than that.
It takes most likely someone who has
probably been molested themselves.
What are you going to like?
Okay,
so you're trying to ultimately beat
me physically and then humiliate me,
but then you still have to get your dick
hard to get it into my bottle, you know?
Yeah. It's an odd, odd
thing to be proud of.
I think if you're a man
and you're doing that,
there's a lot of those guys that have
probably been molested then probably been,
I mean they said that that's one of
the big factors for child molesting his
people who were molested
themselves. Right. As a child.
And I'm not saying that
that's CHOGM lasting, but
fucking rape like that. Right.
It's kind of akin to, right.
It's the number one fear.
If you're going to go to prison,
sons of anarchy just started
the new season. Right? Right.
Amazing. Like it starts with uh,
auto getting butt fucked, you know,
and how rude and he's, he's the
creator of the show, I think.
So that means he okayed himself
getting butt fucked and okayed it.
Guy Probably wrote it in.
Yeah, he wrote it. He's getting
butt fucked. And I'm like,
I'm like,
and then the guy implies this is going
to go down on the regular everyday now.
Oh, so if you know every morning
you're going to get bought fucked.
At what point do you just give up? Like
even fighting it. You're just like, oh,
do you shit yourself every morning so
that the guy has to stick his dick like
through like that shy,
I bet shit's not gonna scare him off.
If I had to take a wild guess right,
and the guy was trying to fuck
you in the butt every day,
that guy's not like discerning, learn to
like it, you know, day two, day three.
Do you just,
you could,
that could be the non passive bluedot
approach and learn to be a good wife.
You know, maybe you actually
grow to love each other.
I mean how it's a terrible
idea to be locked up in jail.
The guy was fucking all the time for sure.
You would probably,
your mind would try to rationalize
and find some way to escape it,
but think about the performance anxiety
of just like just being with a girl girl
regularly,
right?
You're like with her and then you can't
get it up and you're like, oh my God,
how embarrassing. Think
about the performance anxiety
of male rapist who's like,
I'm going to rape this guy.
You beat them up.
You get them down and you rip his
pants down and then you're like, sorry,
give me a second. You're
like, I gotta get this. Well,
it's a perfect example of rape
being not sex. Rape is violence,
right?
You know a guy fucking and raping a guy,
especially if he's not gay.
It's a control and violence thing.
You should get him as,
he should get a known male rapist prison
guy on the show and ask him what he
thinks about to get hard.
I don't think they could do it there.
That's the way I like wrestling mask
two people now taking their minds to
separate places.
You got the guy getting a rape to trying
to think of anything but getting raped
and you've got the rapist.
Trying to think of like something to get
them hard to rape the guy. Yeah, it's
comfortable idea, but it's also an
idea that we kind of understand.
That's one of the more
uncomfortable aspects of it, right?
We kind of understand that there are
guys out there that would rape somebody,
right? They would do it and you train
them to kill. I don't think that guy was,
he could have been a rapist,
but he definitely at least tried
to kill people. Or was it very,
I should say at the very least ready.
Right. I met a couple guys like that.
I met a couple of guys along the
way that we're like really crazy.
One of the guys that I used
to do martial arts with,
he went to jail and came back
a completely different person.
Right. It was weird, man. He came
out like a wild animal. I mean,
he went in, he was a real tough kid
and he went in when he was like,
I guess he was probably like
18 or something like that.
We were around the same age. Right. And
when he came out, he came out years later.
Right. He didn't want to tell
everybody he was in jail.
So he had this crazy
story about, uh, you know,
being away and helping somebody
out or something like that.
And then eventually just confessed.
Right.
But then getting to know him like
he was a totally different person.
It's like all of a sudden
I had to realize like,
oh that the last guy he does not, he's
not here anymore. This is some new dude.
Now I gotta talk to this new dude and
figure out what the parameters of our
friendship our cause
he seems fucking crazy,
but he's been fighting for his life and
it cage right for the last four years.
I mean the dude went away and you know,
he told me about like fights where he
tried to be got a death with a mop handle.
Some guys were coming out of with
Shane came out an animal. Yeah,
I came out of an animal.
It was for real wild animal fight to
the death type shit on a regular basis.
Yeah. Well he was in
jail for drugs. Right.
And so he was in like a
serious jail who's in jail,
I think either heroin or cocaine.
I don't know what it was,
but he was fucking nuts when he came out.
I hate to say how much time I've actually
thought about getting fucked in my ass.
Cause because I've been to
jail a few times, you know,
I've never done hard time,
but I've been to jail a few times
for a few months. And uh, you know,
it's like you have to think about it going
in, I guess especially being an Asian,
right? You go in as a black guy, there's
the blacks, you go into the Mexican,
there's a Mexican gangs, you go on the
whites, do you join the area and whatever.
Um, I have a friend that's Japanese, a
little Japanese guy that went to jail.
And then there's not enough Asians in
jail where they just all have to you.
You have to be friends with the Chinese,
the Japanese, the tie, the food, right.
It's not like, oh, because there's
so few and come on, let's face it.
Everyone likes Asian chicks and so,
especially this pervert over here.
So if everyone likes Asian chicks,
then we're the Asian chicks.
Male rapist want Asian dudes.
Dude,
if you're in jail and you're fucking
white dudes and Harry Fro buttholes and
Mexicans and then like a
hairless Asian clean, you know,
you're like, oh, you know, and
kind of see your point. You know,
it depends on what your agents are small.
We're like, some were smaller than,
so if you're a rapist and look,
I'm just,
this is the things I think about and I
get to jail. I'm an easy target, you know,
I'm not a fucking giant
guy. Like, he's like, oh,
and he doesn't have that much hair. Like
I wasn't a weird thing to think about.
Do you think about this?
Well,
I think about it when I get go to court
and they go, you're going to jail.
You Know How many times you've been in
jail? Uh, I've been maybe five times.
Most of them like just a week or a day.
And then the Japan thing
where I was for three months,
but never more than a few months,
you know, and I never got raped.
It's like almost, it's
almost a weird thing. Like,
I almost wanted it to happen
so I could finally let, yeah,
you didn't try hard cause you remember
the Ed Edward Norton Movie 25th Hour
where we asked his best friend to beat
the shit out of him so he would look ugly
going in. So he looked, he looked like
a bad ass. So I never went that far,
but it was like, God, I forgot about that.
You know what a crazy strategy. Yeah,
but it's like, it's okay. I
get to prison the first day,
a white gang, Mexican gang,
whatever is like, let's, let's
fucking show the new guy,
like how it's done here. I'm
like, at that point I'm like,
I'm going to be overpowered, whatever,
this and that. I was in my mind, I,
I made it up very early on. I was like,
I'm not going to get fucked in my ass.
It's not going to happen.
If I go to jail and like five guys hold
me down and fuck my ass or whatever,
then I'm going to die the next day.
I don't want to be the guy that gets,
I'm going to fucking kill
the guy that did that to me.
And if I die trying then I'll just be
dead. But I'm not going to like, you know,
if they make me suck their dick, I'll
bite their dicks off. You know, I'm not,
I'm not strong statement,
you know,
like I'm not going to fucking be the guy
that just gets bought. Fuck, you know?
I know what you're saying. What if you
like it though man, that is the problem.
Like I think you're going to like it.
Well you know you have that bingo
button in your prostate or whatever.
So allegedly, allegedly, I never pushed
that bitch. I don't want that job.
But the, on a regular like, you
know you've trained martial arts,
this and that and I've heard like the
Bruce Lee story stuff where he's a bad ass
so everyone always tries to fight
them. Ray, like on a regular week,
how many times does someone try to fight?
You know,
or never will never try to find me.
I'm very nice. I know you're a nice,
he comes up to me, I know you're a
nice guy, but does people ever go, hey,
you think you know a lot of fights?
No, no. You know, I, I'm not like, uh,
I'm not very impressed
with myself. You know, I'm,
I'm not like type of person who
brags about what I can and can't do.
So it's not like I have to
respond to things that I've said,
like I could kick this guy's ass.
Fuck that guy up. I would never even,
I don't even think like that
or do it for me to do it to,
to calm my crazy monkey body. Right.
I do it to keep my mind straight.
I do it to give myself something to
something that's very difficult to do
because I think that as a person,
oftentimes we have a lot of intensely
built up stress because of the nature of
average everyday life in comparison to the
ancient man had a completely
different existence. Right?
But we essentially have the same body
that body has like energy requirements.
And I find that if I don't test myself
at some extreme way on a regular basis
physically,
that I can't stay calm.
Well, I tried to push me like I've
been painting my whole life. Right.
So I guess when any anyone does anything
their whole life to other people,
it makes it look easy. Right,
right. So I'll paint and you know,
I'll just pick it was,
and I paint quickly so I don't really
spend too much time on any one painting,
you know? That's because I've
practiced in practice. You know,
what's your style too? Right? You have
a very particular style, you know,
people will see me painting and
go, Oh, I think I could do that.
I thank you very much for the Werewolf.
That was cool as shit
framing was done. I'd have it hanging
out while you're in here. But that was,
well that was cool to find out.
How much do you like comics and the
horse shit growing up in that, you know,
that stuff.
For me it's fun to paint.
It was, to me it was so fun like the,
the old creepy and eerie and all those.
And, and Dude, you bought me a whole book
series to you. You're the nicest guy.
Oh a man. Well, I bought
me a whole book series of,
of those comic book a horror things.
Wow.
Look, I was bad. I had been
doing this show for four years.
Right? I'm all set. Yeah,
I'm, I'm a baby. But you've been like
on fear factor. You're, you're in Bro.
You've been in broadcasting for
awhile. Like broad casting. Yeah.
Well you've been in front of a
camera too. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
I'm new to this shit.
You know, it's, and I,
and that's another thing for me
to challenge. You know, like I,
my podcast is barely a year old that when
I did the show for vice to thumbs up,
I was just fumbling and fumbling through,
like making shit up.
The device. Things were cool, dude. The
vice things, it got people to know you.
But I first heard about
you, I'm sorry, go ahead.
It's just a lot of stuttering though,
right? And there's no, there's no person,
there's no script. I'm just like, uh,
and so to have like you,
Kevin Smith, Anthony Bordain,
Howard Stern,
like all these guys like let me be on
the shows and interview them like a,
I get ridiculously sick before the show.
Like I just get filled up with so
much like nervous energy and like,
well I'm more calm now,
but like the first time I was on your
show I puked like outside of Chili's or
something right here or a did you really?
But I would never expect,
I would have never believed that.
You seem so calm and relaxed.
Also it had a little food poisoning then,
but just in general,
anytime,
like I have a lot of anxiety with
being like in front of cameras,
cameras or like anything like this. I like
it because it makes me nervous. Right.
In the same way.
Like I would like someone to at least
attempt to try to put fuck me in prison.
It's like it gives,
it's an insane amount of nervous energy
where it gets shaky and then I just puke
it out and then I'm good. You know? Like,
it's one of those things
that I think once you start,
once you start it right and then
you just get comfortable and, and,
and so I'm appreciative to
you and everyone who's like,
let me be on their show and talk.
So it's like, I think it's uh,
a little bit of a lost art of
writing a nice note or like,
you know, it's like, hey, hey bro, had a
good time. Send a text message. It's like,
okay, cool. But like, you know,
someone does something nice for you,
like do something nice.
I write,
really recognize the Chester and I
really appreciate it. It was very,
very cool of you and very generous.
But I don't,
and now I don't want people who've been
on the show now just start sending me
shit. Call David. Charles says,
well that's the thing. It's like,
I don't want to send
people shit that I hate.
Like I have a hard time throwing
stuff away and people are like, Hey,
you're an artist.
I'm an artist.
And they send me a giant like
shitty painting. And I'm like,
this is so sweet that you did this.
But I sort of feel like shit now because
I inspired you to paint this horrible
picture and I, you know, I've had a
lot of space to put it, so I'm like,
I have a real tough time
throwing stuff away. But like,
I know you like Werewolf Shit and you
told me you liked the EEC horse stuff.
So I'm like, Joel, like this. Uh, it's
very cool. Very cool. Thank you very much.
And I went to Kevin Smith's house. He has
a shitload of Batman toys, so I'm like,
this guy for sure likes Batman toys,
but he doesn't have the best ones that
I know about. So it's like, you know,
I like, I like getting people
stuff that they want, you know,
not like just bullshit, you know? That's
very, very cool. Very cool. If you man,
yeah, you're a, you're
a very thoughtful guy.
I would've never thought that you were
nervous the first time he did it because
he was so calm and normal and relaxed
and honest. Well it goes from this,
it goes from retardedly
nervous, like, like,
like I can't like I get filled with,
and one of the main things that
people say about me is like,
I interrupt people or I say like too much,
but it's because I have so much.
I, it's all in me. And like I don't,
I don't know how they should go. Well,
I seen you do it right.
And I seen Howard stern do it and I seen,
and to me I see Joe pulled up to the show,
sit down,
have a coffee and start talking.
And that's how I do everything.
That's how I do art. People go, what
do you think about when you paint?
What do you I go, I don't think about
shit. I like, I know you have your um,
deprivation chamber stuff to relax it and
stuff. But for me, like for podcasting,
for playing music,
for making art,
I sit there, I try to like
do the yoga, not yoga,
Zen, uh, a meditation shit of
just thinking about nothing.
Like just blank, go blank, like from
the Ghostbusters, think of nothing.
And I just try to think of nothing and
then I just try to explode, you know.
But then I walked in on,
um,
the Nerdist they broadcast from meltdown
and they had all these writers writing
shit. And I think they do
that for the stern show too.
And I'm like, this is crazy.
They like preparing the, you know, and
so for me, I don't do any of that shit.
I just show up.
I turned the mics on and I start talking
for like 10 hours straight cause I
usually do four podcasts back to back.
But it fills me with such nervous energy
and it takes me a second where that
nervous, I puke it out
first, then I calmed down.
And then in the same way where people
are like, oh, when they see me paint,
they're like, oh, I could do that. Cause
I, cause I make it look easy. Whatever.
I do the show with Joe and then I'm like,
I think I've had kicked the
shit out of jail. Not that bad.
I think I could fight him. I think I could
take them. You, yeah, you relax a little.
Um, I think too that the, it's such
a unique medium, the podcast medium,
and it's really, it's a medium that
like works best when you do it this way,
in my opinion.
I think there's two types of podcasts.
It's like the Dan Carlin type podcast,
right?
Which we were talking about last
night with a Wayne Fetterman,
who's a buddy of mine,
who's a,
of a hilarious comedian who became a fan
of that hardcore history podcast, right?
But it's not really a podcast
the same way this is, right?
It's more like an audio book,
like at Lecture, brilliant,
entertaining lecture on history,
whereas the,
but that's like a preparatory
thing or a preparation thing.
But what we do is, you know, essentially
it's done best when it's like,
who is David Choe today? Like we
very, who's David showed today,
September 12 2013 where are you at right
now? What's going on right now? Where,
where you had in your, your laundry list
of experiences in this life. And that's,
it's very unique in that way.
And a guy like you. You know,
the only way we were talking about
this before we even started, right?
But about people wanting
to do something with UL,
we get you David Chair and get you. We
know you're wild. We know you're crazy.
We'd love that.
We want you to do that on our thing.
And then once you get involved with
it, you realize like, oh no, this is,
they don't get me at, no, no, no, I can't.
You're telling me to do this and I
want to do that. And you telling me,
I can't swear and I can't say that
I shouldn't say this and that'll,
that'll stop them from advertising.
You know, hiccups. Fucking laundry is
the most perfect media to express myself
when I'm not painting or doing anything
because it's first of all,
the shits free.
I don't have any ads and you don't
have to listen if you don't want.
And I know what I am and I
know what I'm not, you know,
I don't know shit about history.
I don't remember dates.
I'm not that smart where I'm going to
actually inform you about anything.
Like I,
I just know that I have a
feeling when I isolated myself,
when I'm, when I'm a bit of
a recluse and I don't go out,
that the evil thoughts start coming
in and they start feeling like a weird
person. And I'm like, does anyone
else feel like this or is it just me?
And a lot of times it is just me. But
like, you know, I get, I get all anxiety.
And so then I go see a
therapist and I'm like,
I don't even know if this is for me.
So for me,
the podcast is me and my friends
bullshitting. I talk about shit,
I know fucking art hanging out,
this and that.
And then I could just verbal diarrhea,
all my problems out and you can
listen or you can not listen.
But by me doing that,
I'm exercising my demons and you
could relate or not relate and go,
this guy's a Weirdo or, or not. And I
can only, I can only talk about what I,
what I know. And I, I'll
give you an example. Uh,
I just, for the first time in four years
had my first art show. I haven't painted,
uh, I did a few murals,
murals and shit in that time,
but not like an actual art show in a
gallery or museum. And you know, I,
I'm at a point in my life where money is,
I don't need to play the money game,
which is a very rare thing to say. Like,
I don't have to make money doing anything.
I don't have to make money off my podcast.
I don't have to have an art
show and sell it out. Like,
so if I'm not playing the
same game of most humanity,
most people will never get a
chance to say that, right? Like,
I don't have to worry about money.
My kids don't have to worry about money.
Their children don't have
to worry about money.
So I'm starting to do some more
charitable stuff to help people.
And as far as art goes,
I didn't become an artist so that
only rich people can afford my art.
So I'm trying to do shit that's free
and museums, more murals, whatever.
So I did, uh, I did my art show in Mexico,
but immediately after the art show,
and actually it's still up if anyone's
in Mexico City and wants to see it,
it's at the Museum del Chapo at,
and it's called Snowman monkey barbecue.
And it's like, it's an old
camp, a gambling term that, uh,
um, is that online? Can we see that
image? Yeah, you could see shit online.
What is it? Snow man. What?
Snowman monkey barbecue. Dot. Mx.
Um, and so, um,
I, I'm, I'm like,
that was crazy because I had two and a
half weeks to put that show together,
you know,
and I did murals and watercolors
and sculptures and all that shit,
so. Wow. What is, what's
going on back there? Oh yeah.
I just made shit out of, uh,
uh, Penn Yada material,
that fucking thing.
And I'll be, is that man? Uh, I dunno.
It was like three stories high and shit.
So it's insane. That's a real
work of art. But, so it's like,
uh, it's, I haven't painted in
four years. I'm fumbling around,
I'm doing bullshit. And then someone's
like, here's this space at a museum.
You got two and a half
weeks ago. Just puking
it all out. You know,
go back to the one large image of it.
If you would see seats filled out
up with this cane, what did that,
that's fucking crazy. Look like a giant
Eagle looking thing. Yeah, I mean it's,
it's everything I saw in Mexico,
everything that I felt and I just,
you know, and I'm confident at this
point in my life to pink, you know,
when I was younger,
I would see something in my head and
the hand eye coordination of like,
it wouldn't look exactly how I saw it.
And now I can make exactly
what I see in my head come out.
So to your hand is filming
you make me nervous.
So I just puked that shit out,
you know? And then, um, Brian,
I don't think you can show that.
Think get in trouble.
So we're not really gentlemen.
They were definitely not real. Um,
so then I was at a dinner,
um,
a year earlier with Anthony Bourdain
and David Chang and there's a food
symposium in Copenhagen every year
called mad symposium and it's like a food
conference, you know, and it's
just all Michelin star chefs.
Like pick the guys that do with food,
that kind of shit. You know too.
That's so cool. Okay. I
know that young child girl,
boy in the lower right hand corner
with the Eagle thing over its head,
what kind of bird is that?
If you saw that in detail,
it's just goes deeper and deeper. Like
the girls being eaten by like a parrot,
but then her beak turns into another
thing and there's a blue dog.
I try to see fractal almost.
Well I tried to do this like,
well I could talk to you about it
because you understand that I wasco,
the Iowasca open something inside me
where I'm tripping all the time now.
Well I'm tripping all the time.
She go to a doctor. I mean it's,
they broke your trip. No, it's crazy
man. Like you're tripping all the time.
Like it's happening, you
know, like you do mushrooms,
are you Iowasca then you
start seeing shit, it's just
happening all the time now.
So you see it all the time.
All the fucking time.
Like Jill would just be sitting
down when I'm seeing it right now.
Like there's like a train track right
here and then there's like weird colors
coming down this way. Um, really, I don't
want to sound like a Weirdo, but it's
weird.
I don't try to fight it.
The images are just exploding.
I mean I could differentiate between
reality and whatever. Right. But it's,
if I just close my eyes like that time
before you fall asleep and I just lay
there, I could just watch like this
symphony of, I don't know what it means.
I don't try to make sense of it,
but it's happening.
So it happens on a super
regular basis all the time.
And it only happened once you had
your initial Iowasca experience?
I did,
yeah.
And in one year I did mushrooms a few
times and I did Iowaska three times back
to back.
And since then it opened something
inside me. And you know, it's the
same visions that I would see,
like if I had a dream or whatever,
but now it's just all the time.
It's never, there's no like, oh, now
I'm going to trip. And the IOWASCA,
that's the Iowasca on the third night.
Oh my God, I was on the third night,
you know the call it the spirit,
it talks to me and it said to me,
don't ever do this again. You
got, you got your homework,
now you know what you need to do. Wow.
And I wrote everything down and said,
you need to do this,
this and this.
And it gave me instructions of all the
shit I need to do for the rest of my life.
I couldn't do an eight lifetimes,
you know, 20 lifetimes.
And it says you could abuse anything,
right?
I could start doing IOWASCA
recreational. It's, and it's,
it's a powerful tool and I don't
want to abuse that. And you know,
so I'm like,
why would I need to do something?
I mean it's, I can, I think I
could still function as a human,
but it's all the time. It's,
it's open now and it's uh,
it's cool. I like it. Yeah. I love it.
It's not like maddening or whatever.
It's like,
um,
I wish this is one of those
days where like, you know, if a,
you and I were not in the same
room, right. And I'd say, well,
show me what it looks like. Uh, you know,
if you were describing a physical object,
you can take a photo of it, send
it to me. Right. Right. One day,
I hope that technology exists that I
could actually see what you're seeing.
I could you imagine if we found out
that like your version of like various
things that you're looking at is different
than my version because you do it and
you're like, it's crazy Dave. And I
go but explain crazy and I'm like,
is your crazy the same thing
that I'm seeing, you know? Well,
it's like how much of you,
what you impart as beauty to something
is based on your own personal or cultural
context. And if you could
absorb another person's views,
right? Like, if you could see something,
maybe an actual
visualization of something,
it's not just the image itself,
it's the emotions attached to the
image automatically by the mind.
And I think we all have
different ones of those,
which is why some dudes like girls that
are like really kind of overweight,
right. You know, and some girls like
really skinny guys or some, you know,
it's like you, there's
something, it triggers in you.
The one thing when people do
like dream analysis and shit,
like what does it mean this and that.
One thing that I try to,
that I do a lot is I over analyze stuff.
Like why did I just draw this guy's
own dick going into his own butt?
Or why did I draw like an
uh, blew over and over. Yeah.
Yeah. What did I draw?
Yeah. Why did I draw this,
draw that a hundred times that movie super
bad. When the guy throwing the Dicks,
I was like,
why didn't I get that job?
Nobody draws dicks veins on a
tick better than me. That was
close to home book.
It's everywhere.
If you go to any country and you
take a shit in any public bathrooms,
someone always draws a dick.
Yeah.
What is desire to draw dicks
and a peace symbol of fuck you.
You know? Right. There's always the,
it's always goes back to the dig, well,
who are these bathroom philosophers?
I do. It. Is that quest people, right?
Like shit down on a wall. It's a, it's
a weird thing. It's like you're, you're,
uh, we're all admitting
that we're experiencing the
same uncomfortable moment,
right? So here's something to
think about. Distract you. Right.
Well, so when you have dreams and
you have visions and you're like,
what did that mean? Did something
happened in my life that day? Um,
I did a lot of over analyzing like that.
Like, why am I seeing this right now?
Why is this dog's head exploding?
And then a mushrooms coming out and then
flowers are coming out of the mushrooms
and this and it's turning
into my mother's face. Slap.
Like w instead of thinking about that,
I just watch it now instead of trying
to be like, why is that happening?
It's just like, cool, this is happening.
And in the same way that mural,
everyone's like, it just kept changing
every day. And it's like, what is it?
Is it a animal or is it this? And what
was happening in my life during that time?
First of all,
there's an unbelievable amount of pressure
as an artist after not having a show
in four years to, you know,
every time I do a show,
I want it to be the best
show I've ever done.
And this was like such a small amount of
time to put that much art together that
I was, you know, everyone's like, you
fucking bitches in Mexico. I'm like,
I'm working. I'm not, I didn't
go to Mexico to fuck, you know?
But he was a very strange way of saying,
fuck, how did I, how do I say it?
It's very bold. Oh, really? It's
like I didn't bravado to it like,
you're wearing a cape. I didn't go to
Mexico to fuck up. It's like you're,
you know, a confident way of saying, fuck,
why do I, what do I like to do? Fuck.
Just like it's, you're, you
almost defiant in your tone.
So I got to tell you what happen
and I, I uh, you know, cause every,
I'm going to go off subject
just for a second, cause no way.
Every time on the show,
every time I think, wow,
I've experienced a new sexual thing
that I've never, like, this is insane.
Like how many are left when a girl's
shoots a ice cube? My butthole or, or,
or you know,
like,
or like when I'm laying down and then
like five women are just giving me a
massage just using their
tongues. I'm like, oh five,
it's not going to get better than
this. You know, this is like a baller.
Damn. I didn't know who it went over to
handed. I thought it just stopped there.
You got five and then so I meet a guy,
yes,
your day. And he's like, Oh yeah, we did
some rate red rope shit and this and that.
And I'm like red probe. I'm like, I don't,
I don't know what that is. He's like,
you don't know what the red
rope services? And I go, no,
but please tell me like, what the
fuck are you talking about right now?
My name is Marty and I'm the
inventor of the red rope service. So
sitting there, okay, so you're laying
on your, it's a massage parlor. You Go,
it's not, it's a service. It's not the
name of a place. It's like a code word.
You Go, can we get, can I get the red
rope? Okay, so you're getting a massage.
I think it's only in Asia.
And you're laying on your back
and then you go, you know, you get,
you get to the happy ending point where
she gets her dick hard and everything
and you're like, I would like the red
rope at this point. She ties a rope.
And here's the crazy part. It doesn't
have to be read. It's just the rope.
And they tie it to the whatever, the,
the bars above the massage table.
And they hook their feet on
it so they're upside down.
And so they start spinning around and
then they put their mouth on your hard
dick.
And then they let go and they helicopter
their mouth around your Dick all the
way.
And I'd never done it before,
but the guy says it feels like your
Dick's can it like you've never felt
anything like that before in your life
and it feels like your Dick is just going
to explode with, uh, you know,
like a neutron bomb and
explosion and then you,
and then it's done and it stops and then
it spins the other way around to listen
to the crafty.
Always unbelievable because they,
they really like take
sex to another level.
Like they try to figure out the most
pleasurable things to do to you and then
they do them, you know, so wrote books
about it. I mean, you know the the,
what does that,
that book the um,
what's the fucking the famous a tantric
book. Yeah. What the fuck is that book?
Um, for me, uh,
well here's the thing about the red
rope or any of that shit. What the fuck?
I know what you're saying.
I know what you're talking about.
Cause I do that tantric shit. God Damn
it. What's the name of the book though?
There's a famous name that if you find
it over people's houses, like, oh,
they're a freak. I, yeah. You
know what I'm talking about?
I know what you're talking. I do.
I do. Student of Tantra. So fun.
Have you ever had a soapy where you're
on a raft and they put like soap all over
again? Then you just wrap
your body up and down. Brian,
I've done it on the red
rope. Well, here's the thing.
Here's all the shit that we're talking
about, right? The soapy raft. Yeah,
the red rope, whatever sutra.
The conversation. I mean, um,
here's the thing about all
these weird sex things,
especially like at a massage parlor
where they do those things. You're like,
how does one girl do the red rope?
She had to learn it from,
they have to teach someone who does
a happy ending. Like amazingly,
the quality of service has to maintain,
you know,
like how can one girl give the
best hand job? She had to learn it.
So that's another thing I think
about, you know, who's teaching him,
who's teaching them? Is it a client
down? It's gotta be who's the Guinea pig?
The guy who owns the building,
who's the Guinea pig guy owns a building.
No fucking big mayonnaise
jar fill. Viagara. Exactly.
So I don't know if you know this Joe,
but I like to gamble. I know I haven't,
I haven't gambled in, in almost a year
and eight months now. No one's counting.
But uh,
I used to gamble in Macau and cow is like,
it's Times 10, it's Vegas Times a thousand
a thousand. They do shit in Macau.
That shit's on v one. One
good casino in, in, uh,
in Macau makes more money
than all of Las Vegas.
Like they're finishing out there is two
football fields wide. Like it's crazy.
Oh my God. And they have
chips. Like, you know,
you go to Vegas and you see black
chips and green chips, whatever.
They have like square chips, the size of
this and you're like, Whoa, what's that?
And they're like, that's a million
dollars million dollars. China,
if you ever thought China's
going to run the world, yes.
The answer to that is yes.
They don't give a shit.
They have money there that it's like
you wouldn't even fucking understand.
It's not a good thing or a bad
thing if China runs the world, uh,
I mean you say China and everybody
goes communism, tenement, square.
Those are two things that come
up. Communism, tenement, square,
and then you say America. And what did
they say? Hiroshima. Nagasaki, Kent State.
You know, it all depends on whether
you like Chinese food or not. You know,
like if you like MSD then it's
good that, I don't know. China,
Chinese people running shit. Who
knows? I do know that if you, uh,
to the like the three listeners
out there that oriented Asian guys,
if you like Asian dudes,
if you like, you know,
the hairless body and all that shit data,
Chinese guy from China,
because there's so many of them because
you don't want to date a Korean because
they're fucking assholes. They're
stubborn, insecure, judgmental assholes.
You don't want a date, like
a weird Japanese guy. China,
Chinese like to fuck. They like to
fuck a lot. Whoa. That's why words.
That's why there's billions of them.
There's more of Chinese than anywhere.
There's more Chinese people got to
get good point there. I'm right.
They know what is that point? They
don't like. They don't like to pull out.
They like to come inside and they like
to have babies so much that there's
billions of them. Overpopulation.
What does the Chinese government to,
you can only have one child. Now you can
only have one if you can only have one.
What do you want a boy?
What did the Chinese people do now?
For years now you can only have one kid
or else you have to pay crazy taxes.
So if you're trying to use,
and you have brothers and sisters,
that means your parents would probably
rich. So you owe port till you have a son.
So what does that do
to the population now?
There's way more boys than there's women.
What does that do now that now in the
same way they used to do the mail,
a Russian mail order bride.
Now they do that for China
with Vietnamese in Filipino,
there's not enough women so that
they need to do Filipino mail order,
bride time mail order bride.
And what does that do? There's,
I don't know,
I don't know statistics,
but I think it's something like 10
for every 10 guys. There's one girl.
So what does that do to the entire
country? He creates homosexuality,
more higher numbers.
And if you're,
if you're a dude and you're
lucky enough to get a girlfriend,
you're going to treat her amazing.
You're going to treat her like
a fucking princess. So ladies,
if you like the Asian,
get a Chinese,
it seems like a recipe for fucking chaos
because it doesn't seem like if you
live like that and you
only have one child and um,
the majority of them
are men at first of all,
it doesn't feel like that's sustainable,
but it feels like people are
going to be so unhappy. Well,
if we're going to be so
crazy and I want answers to
book called the Kama Sutra and learn some
tantric shit so you don't fucking come
inside and have so many,
we got them babies, you know, that's
not going to help at this point.
At this point.
It seems like when you have that situation
already in place where you're only
allowed to have one kid,
so you have this excess of males
and completely imbalanced set up.
Whenever you have imbalance like
that, it creates unrest. It's bad.
What they could be doing is setting up
their entire country to change the tone
of the country.
Right.
Well,
here's the thing that I know,
I know when a shit is fucking crazy
because the art gets really good.
You know, are in China is better than
the art and the rest of the world. Why?
Because they have been tormented.
Yeah,
because they have been
living under communism,
like Brian only fucks porn stars and he
thinks it's going to be a step up for
him to start dating artists.
That is like 10 steps down.
Wait til you hear his comedy
after he starts dating an artist.
It will be the best comedy he's ever done
in his life, but because they're crazy,
they're horrible.
Especially once the paint a lot of self
portraits of themselves. No, I mean,
come on,
give me a fucking break. Hey,
let's not get specific here.
It's not going to have civic,
but you know what I'm saying.
I know exactly what you're saying.
So
like,
um,
so I'm in China and I'm gambling
and I get stressed out and they go,
do you want to go get a massage? And I,
and I told the guy, he goes, you know,
a massage or a massage. And I go, no,
like, seriously, like a regular massage.
I want to calm down.
So he gives me the number for this place
and like old Macau and I go in and it's
amazing.
It's like giant,
huge sofas where he could kick
back and the guy runs and goes,
do you want a sandwich and some
ramen or whatever. I'm like, yeah,
give me some noodle soup. Gimme a ramen
than a dude rolls up. And he's like,
you got some like hard skin
on the bottom of your feet.
You want me to shave that off? I'm like,
yeah, fuck yeah. You know, wait a minute.
Many petty dude and the Andy Petit.
Yeah.
So I got a dude shaving with a razor
blade, like the hard skin on the,
off the bottom of my shoe.
And then a little girl just comes
and sits on my shoulder and she goes,
do you want your ears
clean? And I go, yeah.
And she's doing like little
flowery shit blowing in my ear,
digging all this like earwax out.
And I'm like,
I feel like a goddamn princess right now.
And then a sold a sort of like milfy
older, not that attractive, but you know,
got some weird meal. Five, that's my
time comes up and goes, do you want to,
do you want a leg massage? And, and
this is all like 30 bucks, you know,
like now I got three people catering to
me. I got one dude on my feet, one chick,
uh, cleaning my ears. And I think at one
point I had four, like one chick was like,
do you want to head scalp massage? And I
was like, let's just do the whole thing,
you know, so you're just sitting
there like a goddamn king.
And then the lady that's
giving me my thigh massage,
she's like sitting on a little
stoop between me rubbing my legs,
rubbing my calves.
And then once in a while she goes from
one leg and then she goes to the other
leg. And one time when
she went to the other leg,
her hands scraped the bottom of my
balls. I was like, oh, whoops. Sorry.
Like was that an accident? And then
did you ask why? It was like, oh,
that's sort of cool. You
know, I didn't say anything.
I was, I was getting my ears,
whatever I was going on.
But then she goes to the other leg and
this time she grabs my balls. I go,
that's not an accident. So I'm like,
monkey grabs the peach. Right. And,
uh, I'm sitting there and
she starts, monkey grabbed.
And so now she's giving,
she's giving me a,
a h j but not like an aggressive HJ.
It's like just,
she's just playing with my balls. Handjobs
you've broken it down to two letters.
J well, there's the dry Hj, there's a
wet HJ roadmaps terminology right there.
Monkey monkey steals the peach.
But she's just giving me like, um,
just like a boring, she's not trying
to get me off. She's just massaging.
She's just being nice to you and I and,
but then I started getting hard and I'm
laying on a sofa thing like this right
next to my friend,
like our feet are touching
so it's kind of gay.
He's like to push off me,
I'm getting hard,
so I feel the bottoms of your feet
but there's tow shake with you.
But there's a blanket over my,
my Dick.
So I started getting hard and she starts
hitting it on her hand and showing my
friends, he's like, look your friend
very hard. And I'm like, don't do that.
They'll do that. And uh,
and I'm like, this is weird.
I'm getting a sexual act. While other
people are like, hmm, like hearing me,
you know, that's so crazy. And it was,
and then it's 15 minutes that she stops
and she goes, do you want it to go on?
Or whatever. And I'm like, let's
stop for right now. Let me, let me,
let me just try to figure out
what just happened right now.
He's not like a business manager. Let's
stop for right now. Let's stop right now.
We're going to get the team
together. Where we go from
here. So they all stopped.
They go away and I go, Bro, that girl was
like said, do you want to find massage?
And she was massaging my balls
and he's like, that was awesome.
And then we're talking and
we're looking at everyone.
So we look like the feet manicured.
People are mostly dudes.
The ear cleaning chicks are usually like
really small because they sit on you
and the five massage
ladies for the most part,
and they all have different colored
jackets to, this is what my job is.
So the Thai massage ladies are all milfs,
they're all,
they're all older and they're not all
hot and some of them aren't even hot.
Then I saw one with the thigh massage
jacket that was young and beautiful and I
said, hey, Hey Thai massage my
massage. And she's like, ah.
She had a weird look and I
was like, what? What, what?
And then the old one that just gave me
one comes and goes, you don't want her.
And I was like, no, no,
no, I do. And she goes,
first day doesn't know what she's doing.
Lecture. And just perfect, perfect.
I want here. And she goes, no,
no, no, no, no, no. And she
goes, you don't want her, like,
I'll do it. I'll do it again.
I know what I'm doing. And I
go, no, no, no. I want her.
And she's like,
I'm not none now.
And they start speaking in
Chinese and they go like, okay.
And then all this shit I'm talking about,
the dreams came true.
They tell me to get up. I go into a
side room and she trains her on me.
I'm the Guinea pig. They never
even look at me. She's the,
the young ones like this. He
starts giving, he's like, no, no.
And she starts yelling like
this and they're having a fight,
arguing over my Dick, practicing,
giving me a hand job, and I'm like,
this is the best day of my life.
Wow.
I'm the Guinea pig of the girl that gets
trained on how to give a Thai massage
and you're in Macau and I'm in McKell.
He must've felt like you
in an Indiana Jones movie.
I always feel like I'm in an Indiana
Jones. I'm always short round.
I just stepping on session cookie.
That sounds incredible.
That sounds like the craziest freakiest
experience ever. It was, it was amazing.
And it,
it was nothing close to sexual for them.
I was just a fucking piece of meat and you
know, she was like, like this. No, no, no,
no, I'm not, I'm not like, I was like,
I want this to go on forever.
And you know, it's amazing.
So things like this happen and then,
and then I have you say, I say, fuck,
I talked about this shit.
You know, and it's like,
it's sort of like suicide to
just keep openly talk about.
But the freaky chicks that listened to me,
they hear me say a story like this and
then they're like, oh, I'll fucking,
I'll do some shit to him that he's never,
so why would you say it's suicide?
And talk about things like this.
Um,
there was a girl that I really liked
a long time ago when I did a different
podcast called Koreans gone bad.
And I was considering,
I've been single for eight years now
and I was considering dating her,
settling down and she goes for her
first thing was no more podcasts.
Like I can't be like with a dude that's
talking about people practicing handjobs
on his Dick, you know, which makes sense,
you know, you don't want to be with,
I wouldn't want to be with someone like
that. And you know, so it's so, you know,
when I put all my shit out there,
I'm on, I have my own podcast, uh,
DVD say were ever besides,
you know, also as a porn star,
but everyone else on the show and they
don't want to share that shit and that
makes sense. You know, they're not,
you know, but she knows who you are,
you know? Right, right. And
you are who you are. You're a,
you're a very interesting guy. The idea
that everyone has to be uniform. Right,
right. And then we all have to fit into
the same pattern of, of control. Well,
what's, what's happened is
I've turned into like, uh,
when guys look at a chicken,
they're like, she's a slut. Like,
that's what shouldn't your mail slot.
That's a chick you fuck.
But you would never take home to your mom.
That's how girls look at me now.
I think some do,
but some probably,
which I love don't they think that it's
probably like a challenge to be the girl
that cracks his, his, his mind
open. It's exciting to me cause,
cause this is what Mary guys,
this is what married guys say to me.
Why don't you get sick of it, Dave? No.
You know why they said
that you get sick of it.
They want you to join their misery.
Well this and,
and I, and I get it. Cause I,
I know like some famous people that do
fuck a lot and they say this shit like
you're getting dangerously close to start
sucking Dick. You know, once you start
it happens, you know, listen
to this. Listen to me.
This is the problem with married people,
right? This is coming from a duties. Okay.
All right.
Married people are much like,
people that want you to use the same cell
phone services. Then they're like, dude,
why are you with Verizon?
Atnt you can answer your phone well and
they get like real passionate about it.
They want you to be miserable
with them for whatever reason.
And it's not a knock on and t, it's just
an example, whether it's windows or PC,
there's people that want
you to use what they use.
And people who are married and like,
C'mon Dude,
why don't you fucking get
married man and become one of us?
They just want you to,
they have accepted this new
stage of existence and they
want for whatever reason,
everybody else to be exactly like them
or it becomes uncomfortable cause I do
the same thing.
I go,
why don't you just get divorced and
come fuck all these girls with me.
Take my sloppy seconds. You know, I got
hit with a placebo. Take some shrapnel,
you know, let's take my sloppy
seconds. What are, and I don't eat say,
and you know what? I don't give a shit,
dude. I'm in. I don't you go first.
I'll take sloppy seconds.
Podcast.
Is that an m e double s guys are like,
oh dude,
you're going to fuck a girl. I was like,
you guys all go first. You can go first.
You can take sloppy seconds. I'll
go through, I'll go last. Wow.
Joe and Brian's come out of
how
I saw. How dare you don't
get, I don't give a fuck.
Well you're that would,
yeah,
I can see what I'm girls would have
a problem with Joe. I understand.
I understand that because it's sort of
true. They go, don't you get sick of that?
Another sex story,
another fucking quadruple hand job.
Another like Tom,
I have a problem with people that have
a problem with people that don't get
tired of shit.
Like why do you care?
People have called me a massage
and this says I love love women.
I love them and I'm not sick of it.
Every time I have sex again it's,
I can see the feelings of maybe
I'll get bored of this one day,
but in eight years I haven't.
Why is that a point of concern for you?
If you're a happy person,
if life truly is a temporary existence
and if you are a good person,
you're a very nice guy. So aren't those,
those bases are covered. Then why? What,
what difference? I'm going
to do something. I'm going
to do some math for you. Oh,
Jesus.
I'm 80% happy.
80% of my life.
I'm happy with how I'm living it.
What I'm doing.
20% of my life is miserable. I look
at married people, I go, I want that.
I look at this and that. But I go, at the
end of the day when I do the math part,
the Asian math park, I'm like,
my life is so fucking awesome.
Whatever that next 20% to fill up that
to make it a 100% whatever has to be sole
fucking amazing that I'm going to
fucking risk what I have right now.
You know?
So there's parts of my
life that I'm like, Oh shit.
You know, I don't have a wife.
I don't have kids that say, I love you
dad. She'd like that. But you know what?
80% pretty good. Don't have to give
that up to you know. But you don't know,
Dave, you don't know the love of
a child. That's some shit. I know.
But you'll also don't know the love of
two fucking women fighting over your Dick
that don't speak English.
You know, like, like,
so this is what I think either or,
right.
It doesn't matter.
I know the real promise people want it
to be the way they're living and who
gives a shit. I don't say never. You don't
want someone goes, hey Dave, are you gay?
I go, not yet. I don't
know. I might be one day,
so I might be married one day I put
Google, are you gonna get married?
And I used to say, no, I'm never getting
married, but I might one day I don't,
I don't know if I'm not
here. You know, there,
there's nothing wrong with
anything you're saying.
But here's the thing that I do see with
guys that fuck a lot is they get into,
you know, this, that the
group sex, anal threesomes,
then it goes to trainees. Shemales
sorry, sorry, sorry. Yeah,
I take trainees is derogatory or ts,
dude,
I got attacked by the transgender trainee
is like saying Nigger or Jack or you
say ts or trans or transsexual.
Like,
you know when midgets getting
mad for it's little people or uh,
what's fs with the ts? I Dunno. So,
but you know, you, you keep, you know,
it's when you catch a Hugh grant or Eddie
Murphy in there with like a weird look,
cause they've already
fucked Elizabeth Hurley.
They've already fucked the
hottest supermodels and then
they want something else,
you know, so I understand that too. And
people are like, Dave, the path you're on,
you're going to start letting guys
suck your Dick just, just for fun,
just to feel the stubble on your
balls. You know, you're getting there.
And I'm like, it's possible. Right?
It's possible. Anything's possible, man.
I see fucking blue snakes in this
room right now as your friend.
I would say it's possible.
And I would say don't worry,
because it's not the worst thing
that can happen to you. Right.
There's a lot worse shit. But I'm going
to bring all this shit back to Mexico.
So this is what's going on in my life.
And,
and people tell me Shit about the red
rope, you know, but I get to Mexico,
I'm not there to fuck, I'm there to
paint. But you know the thing about love,
the funny thing I'm
thinking about love too,
you never know when it's going to hit,
right?
You should be entering through bead doors.
Some of those beat doors that they used
to have when you would buy porn when you
were a kid in Mexico. I painted with, uh,
one of the last living, uh,
Mexican surrealists, Pedro
Pedro Fair, Fraserburgh Berg,
which was an amazing experience.
Actual name, Pedro Fraserburgh. Pedro.
He's amazing.
He's old school.
He's like 80 years old still
drinks like Moscow smokes and just,
we just sat and painted.
But I also met the greatest comedian
of all time of all fucking Joey Diaz.
Uh, no, no, no, no. Not
going to use. It's funny, but
this, this is on some next level.
What's this guy's name again?
Pedro of Berg Frey. Frey doe. Uh,
he's a Jewish Mexican, so it's hilarious.
I'm looking him up. Oh, there he is.
He's like, he's like, love your
mother. Fuck the MC. Escher of a,
of Mexican art and you know,
so I'm having like this,
I'm painting with him for the show.
I'm painting my own shit and Oh,
you never know when love's
going to hit you. You know?
So I meet this girl in Mexico
and Mexican girlfriend.
My friends love calling her that and uh,
she doesn't have a phone
that I can text her.
So we have a super like WB Dawson's creek
kind of relationship where she lives
two blocks from my
studio and to contact me,
she has to throw rocks or lighters or
sticks at my window. So that's beautiful.
So I'm like, cool, this is what it
feels like to be a normal person.
Every morning I wake up and I have a job
to paint the show. It's not like, oh,
next week I'm going to be in Cambodia,
next week.
It's like every day I'm painting.
So that feels regular.
And now I have this chick that
really likes me. She's an architect,
I like her and this is what it feels
like to have a girlfriend, you know?
So I'm like,
cool.
And she's super busy so she doesn't
have that much time for me anyways.
And we didn't have sex right away.
I really liked her and uh,
she did this weird move that we
talk about on our show all the time,
which is black people when
they have sex with asa,
they never take their shoes off or
their socks off. Then he traction.
It's a weird thing. Like they'll, she says
they'll even take their pants off too,
and their shoes to take the pants
off and then put the shoes back on.
They want to be able to fuck with
like a lot of force behind it.
And she was the same way. She's
like, she's like, uh, I don't,
I won't take my socks off. The first
time we did it, the lights are off.
She's like, I'm not taking
my socks off. I'm like, oh,
like black guys. And she goes,
no, like woody Allen. And I go,
oh, I don't stop saying that.
So I'm fucking her in the whole
time. She's like, like woody Allen,
like woody Allen. I'm like,
stop saying Woody Allen.
And so I really liked this girl.
I'm starting to, to, to, you know,
this is a joke that I've killed,
but I keep saying it's the worst STD
you could possibly catch feelings. Uh,
so I like her and yeah,
and, uh, it's going good.
And also on the show became a relationship
advice or David Cho and one night,
cause she loves drinking. She's
a hard drinking, Mexico sloppy.
We're having sloppy sex. And she
goes, you like my little piece?
And I go, what? And she goes,
uh, I have a little piece.
I go and, and her English
isn't perfect, so I go,
I don't know what you're saying right now.
And she goes,
it's really shy and it doesn't
come out all the time. And
I go, what? And she goes,
you know, like a little penis. And I go,
and the thing is, every, every night,
every day that I painted in Mexico,
my hands are caked in pain, right.
And I would come home and I'd scrub them.
So like she would let me finger her,
you know, and girls, you know Joe, you
know how many your urinary tracking
podcast is the greatest thing that's ever
happened in my life.
You know how many urinary track infections
these hands have given. I know. No I, I,
I, I cut my nails, I
scrub them, I get all,
even with the scrubbing I get
some pain on still. But you know,
if I'm painting a giant mural like that,
I'm going for it.
And my hands are covered in paint.
And then the,
the chemicals he used to take
the pain off as well. Right?
Doesn't that linger in the scanner?
Exactly.
So I go home and I spend like hours
cleaning my hands cause I want to finger,
you know, can you get a check drunk with
Turpin time? I'm sure you can. You know,
it seems like that would
absorb. Yeah. Somehow
that guy's weird clean because
we're stupid. Don't say shit.
If you just stopped and thought
about half the shit you said,
just cut out half of them,
you'd be amazing.
He'd be like the greatest
podcast side kick of all time.
So right now you're number two.
What?
What do you get from number one is
what do you do from that? Joe? You,
you started having sex with
a girl you really like,
she doesn't speak perfect English and
I don't know what she tells you in the
middle of the night. She has an extra
piece that only comes out sometimes. Ah,
you would have to really decide how much
you liked her. I really did like her.
And so what difference does it mean?
I've seen I've had to grow up.
What does it mean? She said
it and immediately my brain
goes, oh, my transgender.
Well, she thought she said it.
And immediately my brain goes,
oh my God, I'm gonna lose my boner right
now. I'm like, but it only got harder.
I don't, I don't know what that
like. And so means you're a savage.
You enjoying the real prime illness.
I tried to laugh it off. I was like,
what are you talking about? Like I tried
to like, then you came over like a rhino.
As soon as, as soon as she says
it, I, I go for the fingers. Right.
I'm searching and she goes, it's shy.
It doesn't come out all the time. I go,
maybe it's my brain is thinking.
As soon as she walked out that door,
I'm going to Google.
Hermaphrodite is,
is that even how it works at
a penis is inside the vagina.
My Dick is inside her vagina. She has
a Dick in there are dicks or rubbing.
Right now her little Dick
is going into my day.
Most likely it's an enlarged clitoris,
right? Yeah. No, no. Her clit was fine.
You know,
I looked at the clit,
she said it was inside and it doesn't
come out all the time. Wait a minute.
She seemed a real thing or did you like
look this up? Like in medical journey?
I looked it up.
I couldn't find a picture of that.
But what did you do with the girl
that's like [inaudible] her mat.
So this is a hermaphrodite girl that's
like that. What it is, it's like,
this is like right on
the top of the penis.
There's some girls have this little thing
that's comes out and it looks like a
little baby. I can't fit. I've seen that.
I've seen women who have enlarged click
tourists and it comes out and it looks,
um, you know, it looks like a little
penis, but this is not that high.
She had a normal a
clitoris and I'm searching.
I don't,
and here's the thing,
it's a weird thing to say
someone to someone during sex.
It's weird thing to
say. You got to bring it up. You're
going to bring it up. Bring it up now.
So listen, bitch, don't pretend you
wait and join the sweet boy pussy. Well,
let's be honest, and this is a
lot of things, and it's, and it's,
it's a weird thing to say. This
is many things. Yeah. I mean she,
you enjoying the shit out of a bitch?
She's constantly fucking herself and she's
like, oh, your dick got harder. Yeah.
Gas,
right?
Yeah. I'm going to look for images. Human
Hermaphrodite. Okay. Do you find it?
Oh, it's very odd. I don't want to see
what you're looking at right now. Ooh,
it's not what I thought it is.
It's a fascinating,
and because I overanalyze everything,
I start thinking, am I gay now?
And there's a, there's a
little, uh, liberating feeling.
I'm like, yes, finally,
I'm gay. There's nothing about this
girl. Let me see her face. If she,
and you know nothing about this chick
that's male, she's a beautiful girl.
She's cute. That might be a
little hot. Then I'm like,
I found the perfect man woman
because the technical, well,
I hang out with my guy friends all day.
I go on Bro dates and I'm like, man,
I wish you had a pussy. Wow.
That was just so weird to say.
I don't know if I would keep eating
or on a lunch date. And you're like,
how am I am I might need my, uh, I
need my energy to fight this dude off.
I don't know what the
fuck's going down next.
No, you don't have guy friends. Let's
go. I could rip you if I wanted. No,
Greg Greg did.
Simmons has a very funny joke about if
he was trapped on a deserted island and
you get to pick his wife or one of his
friends, he would go, I would take it.
This is great. It's fucking funny. And
he's like, because we would just laugh.
We'd go in the woods and jerk off and
then we'd just be hanging out with each
other and it goes.
If it was by wife who like pop pop,
I'm not doing that bit justice. By the
way, Greg, Craig, I'm paraphrasing.
Pick a guy that you have to be bigger
than him in cases that day comes when you
want to rape your friend.
Awesome.
Why would you rate your friend
if you were really friends?
You didn't jerk each other off. That's
true. Just that's what I owned together.
I'd jerk you off down, but hold
a butt. Just touching. Buttholes
not as gay, but it's all gay. You're all
trying to come. It's gay. You should just,
if you were like at that point we like
rubbing bought halls and you tell him to
check like look baby. I mean we
were on that island for 10 years.
The worst I did his rub
bottles would be like,
why didn't you just suck each other off?
Who Cares?
You pooped in the rabbit island.
He pooped into my boat.
I pooped in his boat wherever I can.
I mean it's not just whether or not,
how long would you hold out in prison? You
know, it's, would you want to hold out,
you want to hold out or would you just
say it's an amazing blow each other half
to just send your mind somewhere else.
You know the whole thing.
If you're getting raped and
you just want to go somewhere,
we're not even talking about rape,
we're just talking about gay sex.
Like you blowing your buddy cause you're
both just collecting coconuts for the
rest of your life on this deserted island.
Occasionally one, if he gets a boner,
come on man. Can you just pretend you
regrow girl bro, I fucking love you.
I shaved you from that snake. First of
all. You right handed or left handed?
I'm right handed but I use my
left hand for a lot of things.
Well,
I'm left handed and I jerk off with my
left hand so we could do side by side and
also, but the thing
is, did you do that for
holding an iPad with your right and you
get like really good with the iPad and
you're just like, oh I'm amazing. I'm
like Tom Cruise in minority report.
But I just closed my eyes and I just try
to pretend like it was my dick. Okay,
I'm drinking off mine.
It'd be like doing the stranger when you
sit on your hand and you make it go now
it was a girl for five minutes.
Jesus Christ. How hard would it be?
Why don't you just fucking with something
hot oil in your hand and jerk your
friend off? How much Jesus Christ, it's
not gay. You helping each other out.
He both trapped.
Is it gay to get a massage?
I used to think it was gay to get a
massage by men until I realized that it is
gay until they stick their fingers in
your bubble. I'm a manly man and I design,
I need hard massages and just get a
regular massage. Oh cause I'm thick. Well
I know a couple of Thai girls that
would take care of you ever go to a guy?
Trust me dude, they can't do it. I get,
I go through these torture deep tissue
massage sessions that you need like a
really strong dude or I do it.
I just,
I'm in pain right now because they've
got a tight chick to just destroy me last
night. Oh really? I was crying. I
was like what is that? What stuff?
She probably wouldn't make me cry though
cause they were a roommate or a manly
man. I'm a savage tribe when it comes to
Thai massages when I step on your back
especially that's,
that is pretty intense shit.
I went to a one once and this lady was
standing on either side of my back and
she had her hands clamped on my wrist
and had my arms like stretch back and she
was just walking up and down
my back and I was like, wow.
Like this lady is probably done
this a thousand million times.
She just had it down. It was
almost like a Jujitsu move. Right?
Like you get really good at a triangle
and then you lock it in tight.
It's just as strong in that position.
That's how she was with
this crazy arm thing.
When's the first time you go to massage
by a guy? Like years ago? A long time ago.
First Time was this, uh, this
Mexican dude who, uh, worked for one.
I think it was a Mexican boxing team.
But you had the conversation in your head,
right? I don't give a shot. I know
he was, he wasn't gay. He was a male.
I'm saying for you, you're like,
we fucked a couple of times,
but it was just because I owed
him money. You had, you had,
you had had massages by women
and you had made up your mind.
It's not storing enough. Actually, no.
I need a man to do it. I actually, no,
I'd never had a massage by a woman. I
had never had a massage period. Oh, okay.
This guy was shocked that I was
a competitive athlete. Right.
And then I never had a massage
and I had done all this, uh,
martial arts competition and everything,
and I never had a size when I was, uh,
when I was young,
like my approach to nutrition,
vitamin supplementation and all that,
it was really kind of crappy, you know?
And so I never got massages when I was
competing. I never did any of that shit.
Right.
This one dude who was a friend of a friend
who had a problem with his shoulder,
he's like, I'm telling you man, this
dude like change the way my body moved.
Like he's, it doesn't feel good. It
fucking hurts. Right. But when it's over,
like everything just sort of snaps
and flows and moves as good. He just,
he loosens you up and he
had this no happy ending,
but he had this way of, uh, it was like a,
I think it's called the a a pressure
release or point release or something like
that. Style of massage where
would just fuck trigger
release. It would just pinch down
on these muscles and pull it across.
It fucking hurts, man. It's
similar in a way to rolfing.
Have you ever had that
done? Yeah. You know,
rolfing is another like really brutal
form of a massage. I've had it all, man.
That stuff's great though,
that, that stuff. If you work
out a lot. I was like, what?
I went,
I had that conversation with myself too.
Like years ago when I lived in New York,
there's a Russian bathhouse,
like on the lower east side. Uh, it's
like a shoe fits and all that shit.
And I was like, shit, I feel like shit. I
should get a massage. And they were like,
there's only do care. There's
only guys. And I was like,
at that point I'd only gotten
a massage from women. I'm like,
what the fuck do I care? You know,
it's not sexual. And it's like guy too.
Well, it's like I had a problem
of getting an a man's Dick. Well,
I had a problem of getting boners every
time I go to massage, no matter what,
just cause I was loved. Someone touching
me like that, you know? So I had the,
you remember the Seinfeld where George
is like, I think it moved with the guys.
So I'm like, I don't even want
to mistakenly get a boner.
But I was like, whatever.
It was like a old, like a eastern European
guy. Bunch of fate or looking dude.
I'm like, whatever. So it looked
like he was like an old man.
He's got to compare him to a movie
star. Uh, is he in your saying sorry,
he looked like bank is are who
the hell's that? Uh, he's like,
be watching indie films.
Just still black and white
now. He's an actor. He,
I think he was a Vincent
Gallo Dad in Buffalo 66
that was supposed to be a
good move is really good. He
spoke gambling. Yeah. Okay.
Wait. Why do you want this visual right
now? I don't know. I'm trying to, oh,
Ben Gazzara. Yeah. Oh, that
guy's a bad motherfucker.
So I'm like, lot of shit. So I'm like,
I'm not going to get a boner during a
banker's hour massage. Oh yes, she would.
I would if it was Ben
Gazzara just out of respect.
And also I hadn't gotten a lot of
massages where I take all my clothes off.
I always like to leave my
boxers on or something.
So I get in the room and he's
like, he's dead. He goes, take off,
take your clothes off. And
I'm like, all right, whatever.
And then he puts the oil on and he
started massaging my butt and um,
it's the, but is the the
exclamation point on his massage.
It's shoulders back to bud
calves back to button. I go,
hey, um, you know, butts not that sore
doesn't, doesn't really like, it's cool.
Like thanks.
And then he just started needing my butt
and start talking about how he misses
home and oh. And I was like,
Shit. I was like, dude,
you got to stop touching my ass, man. I'm,
I'm over it. Like please stop doing that.
And then he kept doing
it. I was like, all right.
He kept doing it and she told him
to stop while he was in his zone,
like just talking to himself,
like pretending like it wasn't happening.
He was ready to suck your
Dick. I was like, all right.
And that was the last time.
How many decks do you think you
probably suck that week? Him Or me? Oh,
uh, it's probably his move,
man. Yeah. I miss home.
The only way to get away from this miss
his penis in mouth. Come on. I just
had the worst massage PR thing.
I'm Kinda, I think I'm done now.
I was in Santa Monica and it was like,
I was trying to think carefully if you
want to say this on the Oh yeah, yeah,
it's fine. But uh, I was actually thinking
like, I'll just get a legit massage.
This place was open really late though,
and it, but it looked really nice outside,
you know, so I was like, uh, are you open?
And I think they might've just sent the
last girl home because I saw this pretty
decent looking girl walk out the
side door and then a nine 30,
you know,
instead of on really for the most part,
no legit massage happening
after nine 30. Yeah. Well,
I would say it's like most of the
massage places closed down around nine,
you know? Yeah. But this was the right
down the street from Bolus. I'm like,
all right, can't be too crazy.
Right. All right. So, uh, I,
I go in and this really old fat
Asian lady was there and I was like,
are you open? And she's like, Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. Should I go in the room?
And I now just always take
my all my clothes off.
I don't even keep boxers on all the time
now just in case if you know the girls
really hot, that's cool, you know?
But I just wanted a real massage and
then she walks in wearing like a dress,
no underwear and like cut really
short and just fat and old.
Like, like a grandma old, like I'm,
and she was dressed up like
totally changed clothes.
I heard somebody go to the bathroom,
so that means she went into the bathroom,
washed herself, you know,
and stuff like that.
Cause she was smelled like this
perfume and then she joined,
she gets on top of me,
removes the towel,
gets on top of me and just
kept on bouncing like I
hurt a vagina was like on my
butthole. Like it was just like, she's
like, yeah, army just bouncing and it's,
she's just like not really massaging
or anything. Uh, I don't think so.
I think I was freaked out
and so I was just like, play
dead, play dead, play dead.
Like don't even like don't make
a noise. I'm thinking like, oh,
I hope she's like really gets off me
if she just was stop, start massage me.
So suddenly she starts rubbing her
hands on my back and hurt shit,
calluses or something because it just
scratched and it was, it hurt though.
Like it felt like she was like stabbing
me like hurry, like, so I'm just like, ah,
ah. And then like she flips me over
eventually and stuff like that.
At any point where you're like, I'm
going to just leave right now. Um, no,
because I didn't want to be
rude and I thought she would,
she was kind of trying and then she,
oh,
she started playing with
my butt and stuff. Like,
like a lot of places give you prostate
massages and I'm trying to like tighten
it up.
A lot of places give you prostate certain
pretty popular compared to what I'm,
I'm really good now at like what you said
like when I'm uncomfortable like shit
like that I will give you
bad at leaving cause yeah.
But like now I walk out of movies, I
walked out of massage. You just get up.
I'm just like, I'm not into this
anymore and I just get up and I leave.
I should have done that yet.
It ended really bad.
And then when she flipped me over,
she just kept on like touching
my dick and I'm like, no,
it wasn't like this and stuff like that.
And then she finally gave up and then
left and then came in and watch like you
didn't get hard for her? No I
couldn't. No, I seriously, I did. I,
I was so grossed out,
I was like freaking out with hide my eyes.
Cause like how many
times have you been back?
I've never get back that. How many times
have you jerked off thinking about it?
Never. She's not in my spank bank.
It was too gross. My spank bank,
there's a massage place by my house,
which that,
listen, let's not name names. No,
no, no. I live, I live in Korea.
Tell, oh cool. And I, I've been going to
this place for over 10 years, you know.
Did they have young girls? No,
it's uh, it's not a sex place.
It's a complete legitimate massage place.
And like Joe,
when I go to a place when it's
like some white chick or something,
it's not a good massage.
You go to the Thai place or you go to the
Korean place where they look like your
mother fucking rip your Shit Up,
Dude.
They go fucking crazy. Like you don't,
they give you, they get in there,
they stand on your back,
they pound your shit and yeah,
afterwards you feel all felt and
nice and flowy, whatever. Geos,
boxing gym in Burbank. There's msis
parlor that's connected to, no, no, no.
That's a good, legitimate,
solid, legit massage.
So this is a place I've been going to for
10 years. Not that much. But you know,
every time I know that I
just want a regular massage.
I know that some chick that looks like
my mom or my aunt is going to give me a
great massage and then
I'm done. You know? So I,
but I haven't been back for a few years.
I moved to New York, whatever. Um,
and my way of dealing with that whole
thing with me puking before going on shows
is I started getting massages and I like
hard ones. I'm like, it has to be a hard,
deep tissue. And I was like, I'm going
to go back to that place. And uh,
so I already told this story, but I'll
tell it quick. It's the same stories.
Yours all the, it's nine 30
or 10. All the, the, you know,
they're not ugly, but they're just
older and it's just, the Mama saw the,
she's like, I'm like, oh,
I'll just come back. And she's
like, no, no, no. Just come,
come in. And I'm like, okay.
Never once even thought that I was
going to get a hand job, you know,
I get in there, she comes
in and then I'm like, oh,
the fucking lady the receptionist has
given me. And I'm like, all right, cool,
amazing massage cracks.
My neck cracking sounds back,
just fucking doing it.
And then, uh, you know,
she flips me over and starts
jerking me off and I'm like,
oh, that's what I thought when I came in.
It was always like a $40 massage place,
like a cheap Korean massage, and then
it was $75 now or something like that.
I was like,
what a $30 increase in like,
what the fuck is that? That's
a bargain and a half. You know,
what could they be doing different?
Maybe it's an incense tax,
maybe it's scented candles that they
have to pay. She flips me over. Yeah.
And, and she goes like, like she just
does a couple of ball flux, like,
do you want this? And I was like, I
was like, no. But I was like, yeah,
no, but you were like 12.
Yeah, exactly. And I'm like,
there's, and I was like, Brian,
I was, yeah. I was like,
there's no way I'm going to get hard,
but because she's a professional. Yeah.
She was getting whatever. She did.
Lots of hot oil. Wow. I'm whoa.
And then I'm pretty sure this is
a massage parlor fo the thing,
the bell from someone else coming in.
Hello is someone in here? She goes, okay,
wait, so mid sure. Tops mid
jerk. She stops and I here,
you know it's like a small place. So I
hear their whole conversation. He's like,
Hey, is Rachel or Jenny working tonight?
He's like, no, everyone go home. Ah Wait,
10 minutes, maybe five minutes.
And I, and I get in the guys,
you could tell he's like, no, I think
I'll call and be like, no, no, stay.
I give you a discount, I'll give you
a $10 discount. And he's like, ah.
And I'm sitting there and my
boners just go on. And I'm like,
cause you're seeing her
actively be rejected. It's
bad on both fronts and just,
and just like, I got a break, I'm like, I
could cut out. Right, right, right, right.
I'm like,
I should leave and then leave.
And then the negotiation is like,
he's one foot out the door. He's like,
I don't know. He's like, no, no, no.
Come in. I'll be done in five. No, four,
three minutes. I'll be finished. Three
minutes. I didn't like. I'm like,
okay,
I'm going to get up. Okay, I'm going to,
I'm going to like count to 10
in my head right now. Time nine,
when I get this one,
I'm going to walk out the door.
So I started sitting up and then she,
the guys like,
I'm going to go and he left and she runs
back in and she goes, lay down and I go,
okay, it's that laid out and now
I'm deflated. I'm like, I said,
it's okay. I'm just going to go.
And she goes, no, no, no, no.
And she starts up again and now she's
just playing with my wet noodle. It's not,
it's like there's too much thought
in and I go, stop right there.
Is there a sad moment in life?
No.
It's tugging on your deck and you don't
want them to, yeah. I'm like, it's, it's,
it's cool.
This lady's fit and it's a dark room.
She doesn't give off. She's
a trained, trained assassin.
She wasn't even worried for
a second. She was okay. Okay.
She reaches up behind her and Tara
is a piece of Saran wrap and I go,
what's going to happen now?
I don't know what this is right now.
And she fucking like put some shit on
my ass and lube and she's like puts the,
she, she holds my legs up like this and
Taft's my legs like, like hold your legs.
And I'm like, okay. So I'm holding
my legs like this and I go,
I don't know what's going to happen
right now, but I'm going for it.
She puts the Saran wrap
over my butthole and I go,
she's gonna Lick my ass right now.
Like through the Saran wrap.
Okay.
To this day besides the
part where when I was a kid,
then I put a vacuum cleaner on my
butthole. I've never felt this before.
She didn't stick her tongue into
my bottle. She sucked my butthole,
she put her lips around my
bottle and sucked and I was like,
never felt that before. Whoa.
Dick gets hard immediately.
A few seconds just shot a load
without even jerking off. Yeah, no,
she jerked me off.
But it was like how much time between
her putting the Saran wrap over your butt
hole and you shooting a
load, how much time fit? 15
seconds to put the Saran wrap,
got five seconds to shoot.
She was at a heart immediately.
Like I was like,
I've heard of girls putting their finger
up a guy's boat and licking it and
right she the button,
she sucked my bubble.
So I,
I am filled with so much
shame. I'm like, Huh. I'm like,
she's like, and you know, she
just throws a towel. I mean
it's like, okay cool. Oh my
God. And I'm like, you know,
does this lady, when she goes to the
supermarket and she buys the Saran wrap,
does the lady know what she's going
to use it for when she brings it home?
And the kids are like, grandma, why you
buy so much Saran wrap every week? Like,
oh my God,
I go in the car and I go,
I can never talk about this day.
And then I told him,
yeah, I mean it was a dare you even
lie to yourself. Well, unlike Brian,
I've been back like several times
now. So, and where's this again?
It was the hit hard times,
you know,
it went from a totally legit place to
suck on asshole with Saran wrap place.
You need to open your shit up a little
more and it's quit judging so much,
you know? Oh, he's not judging. I
had a horrible experience for kids.
Her hands hurt.
She gave me zero and I saw she was,
he gave me some kind of massage. I
would probably have to be honest, man.
Just cause you had a good experience,
doesn't mean you can't
accidentally wind up with a demon.
We all know you could wind up with
a game. That's true. That's fit.
An old lady in Pasadena, she
was soft hands. So it was nice.
I won't say names or faces.
She grind it.
She grinded on her butthole with her
guilt shaved Posi you know, come on man.
What Gil if great grandma.
I'm a little dark. So Joe, I got it.
So Dan,
we keep going off all that fucking
story because one of the great stories,
actually I tell you, it changed
my way of thinking about sweating.
Here's the thing,
it's like that that experience was so
important and so funny and there's so few
people that would express it with the
same kind of honesty and glee that you do
it with that it's almost like a disservice
to man a kind if you decide to settle
down.
We have like a real hard time with
that and anybody who wants to stop your
podcast is a cultural criminal.
This is what I see
do traveling a lot.
The,
this is what I see in Chinese and Italian
culture and it's like in this society
there's a lot of crying. Oh my God, my
husband cheated on me and it's like, yeah,
that's just sort of what guys do.
There's sort of almost like an acceptance
in China and Italy where you got your
grandma and you got your wife.
As long as you're handjobs and girlfriend,
shit doesn't fuck with your family.
It's almost like an understanding of
the wife knows you're going to go get a
massage parlor, hand jobs or
have a girlfriend and it's like,
just don't put it in my face. You
know, like you have a business meeting,
you guys are all going to fuck
hookers, get it, but don't,
don't bring it back to me.
That's it. A lot of European
cultures as well. Right?
Like the prime minister of France didn't
he? I'll openly have, they're like,
they're cool. They're just like, they're
like, I think Monica Bellucci said it.
I want to ask you about this.
Right. This is an important subject.
Okay. What do you think is the
cause for, I mean is it the,
the,
the sexual puritanism of America where
people would judge you on you being a
nice person,
you having fun and just doing,
having these experiences which are
readily out there for a lot of people that
somehow or another it's perhaps perhaps
one of my lecturer exploitative or that
people would have a problem with
the idea of using prostitution,
but at the end of the day you're
not really hurting anybody.
And is that one of the most
important issues to concentrate on?
What is the reason why people
do concentrate on it and
get mad at you and judge
you? And I think it has, it has
to be based on the insecurity.
It has to be based on the idea that
are you kidding out what you're doing?
Of course they would want to do it too.
Well, Hey, you have those sex in Dawn,
dawn guys in here. So there's a
lot of like weird religious shit.
Christopher Ryan,
the guys that wrote the sex at a guy.
And so I think a lot of great guy
by the way. I think I am. Okay.
So I went to the extreme version.
No, that I just came back from
Afghanistan. Right. And you know,
you're not supposed to
judge other cultures. Right.
And I get there and I'm staying with a
guy who runs like all the networks in
Afghanistan, Saddam Hussein, and
he's letting us crash at his place.
And everyone's like, oh man, it's so
backwards out there. Like the girls,
they were the burkas and you only
see their eyes and Afghanistan,
you don't even see the eyes.
It's a
complete,
you don't see like mosquito netting
and you don't see flesh like ghosts.
They wearing gloves,
the shit goes to the feet.
You don't see flesh at all.
The dudes, what are they wearing?
Flip flops. Sweatpants, the chilling.
And it's like, don't fucking touch
my girl. Don't fucking look at her.
And, and you go back to this whole thing
with insecurity. That's what it is.
It's like, Oh, if she cheats on you,
if she talked to another guy, yeah,
we stone her.
We'd beat the shit out of her.
It's like the reason why the Taliban
has no problem getting female suicide
bombers is because your life is miserable.
If you're a woman in fucking Afghanistan,
you know, you, your husband beats you.
And if you go to the
police station to complain,
then the fucking police beat
you for complaining. And it's,
it's just like we had, uh,
two girls that are westerners,
so they didn't have to
wear the full burka,
but they still have to
like cover their hair.
And wear jeans and long sleeve shirts
or whatever and they took us to a,
they took us, they took me to a
calligraphy school to check out that like,
like uh, Arabic like calligraphy style.
I love that shit. And they go, hey,
if you, if we go to the roof right
now, we could see the whole city.
It's a beautiful view. I
go, coolest, check it out.
So they went up first and I was like
drawing with some kid and then critter was
with me and he's like, Hey,
get up here right now. Get
up here. And I'm like, what?
We run up to the thing,
the two girls,
they were all standing on the ledge of
the roof looking out at the whole city,
the junk yard tire shop below the
guys working at the tire shop.
Look up and see two white girls and
they could see their face. They start
jerking off, they pull their dicks
off the out and start jerking off.
And I'll walk by like in a trance
and I'm like, and you're like, whoa,
crazy, crazy. It's like,
think about how much pussy you
already saw today without even trying,
turning on the TV. A Victoria's
secret ad, a billboard, you see flesh,
you go to the supermarket,
you go to fucking whole foods where the
bitches are like wearing short shorts
and it's sex is everywhere.
Think about being a Horny,
horny Arab kid and then you see
a fucking chick, just her face.
They couldn't control themselves and
then they saw us and then they stopped.
But it was like they went into a trance
like that's amazing. It was amazing.
I was like, I never got so much
joy watching another guy jerk off.
Weird levels of like intense
religious respect to sex.
It all goes back to fucking
while it. Well, whether it
does or it doesn't have it,
it's all about control. But when you
see that control implemented on people,
there's always a rebound from it. Right.
There's some crazy reaction to it.
Some fanatical explosive
reaction to it. Right? Yeah.
We have a very real natural built in
response to someone trying to control us
and we either go with it full heartedly
and make it like it's our idea or we
rebel against it and w w and we hate it
and we go the exact opposite direction.
Like Catholic school girls who become
sluts, right? No, that's the wrong slot.
Right? So that's a bad word. Love snow.
Slut shaming on the Joe Rogan experience.
I don't believe in slots.
I think there's people that do
whatever the fuck they want it.
I'm just saying I agree with you.
This society is whatever.
Every society has its problems.
For me personally,
I think if I were to ever get married,
I don't,
I don't want to get into like
some six swinger shit or whatever,
but I think I need to be with like some
European or it's just hold out until the
robots hold out. Until you can get
monogamous robots. What's that shit?
You just show me the silliest rift.
OCULUS rift. Don't, don't buy that.
Don't buy that.
It's going to ruin your life and tell.
I know that I have to go to the mountains
and I fucking put up a high fence to
keep the fucking crazy. Some of
those robots, like the shittier ones,
and they're there in my, in my
closet I bought, I buy every,
anytime someone's like, this is the next
best thing. I buy it with that thought,
when I go to the mountains and
everyone's dead, at least I'll have this,
but I don't open the plastic
cause I know it'll ruin my life.
That's too freaky right now. When you're
dealing with things like, you know,
rubber vaginas are fake. The boxes that
you stick your Dick into and the Gyri no,
it's fake. Right? Even
though it's enjoyable, it's
pleasurable sexual experience,
right? It's removed from
the sexual experience of
having sex with a real woman.
That's not going to be the case 50
years from now, 50 years from now,
they're going to have robotics down to
the point where they can have a real,
bonafide artificial woman who's warm
and feels fucking amazing and is the
hottest chick you've ever
seen on the planet earth.
And you can have 10 of them in
a warehouse charging by solar,
but that will help overpopulation,
don't you?
Well,
it'll help a lot of things,
but like overpopulation is
most certainly a bad thing.
But one of the worst parts about it is
that there's a depletion of resources and
this sort of diminishing of the value
of a human being when there's too many
people.
That's what I think about La and I think
about a lot of places and it's one of
the worries that I have about
China is the volume, right?
And I think my personal experiences,
I've,
I've lived in small towns and I've lived
in, you know, really big places. I've,
I've seen this,
there's a different way that human beings
treat each other when they don't see
each other's often. There's less
of them. They have more comradery.
There's a number that
becomes unmanageable. Right.
I don't know what that number is,
but the group passed it in Los Angeles.
We certainly passed it.
But I think that's
hurry up doctors with that rubber
robot pussy make that. Sure.
I don't think it's doctors
or scientists or whatever,
the scientists and
inventors and modelers and
in the same way,
you know people like adults get weird
when they find out how obsessed kids are
with video games. They're like, we
had PAC man. I'm like okay look I,
what's grand theft auto
on right now? Five. Yeah.
Like when it was on two or
three it you're like wow,
cause you're like a guy running
through a city and it feels,
it feels like virtual reality.
But like you said, it's,
the guy's still looks a little pixelated.
And the facial features, you know,
they do like the stubble but
it looks still like a computer.
I don't know what that says about me,
but like when I would kill him,
hookers and grand theft auto,
the bottom,
the bodies don't disappear as
long as you keep shooting them.
So I would just stand over the hookers
and keep shooting their vaginas,
like admit to that. Well my
little, my little nephew walked in.
Uh, cause I, there was a time
when I got out of prison,
I didn't have a place to live so I stayed
with my cousin and I would play like
Mickey Mouse and the
little kid video games.
And then when they went to sleep I'd
play grand theft auto and he snuck in my
room one day and you know when someone's
in the room and they, you know,
like someone's in the room but you didn't
hear them. So I stopped for a second.
I turned around, I'm like,
what are you doing? He's like,
what are you doing uncle Dave?
And I was like, come in, be quiet.
Don't tell your mom how old is this
kid was like six years old. He's ready.
He was ready, but it's ready to
see hooker. But they're like,
wait till mix next one and the next one.
I'm like video games in the next
10 years it'll, you'll be you,
it'll look exactly like you.
There'll be no glitches where
it looks like a computer.
And so if you're in the game
raping, killing, pillaging,
that's going to fuck with your head.
Even more like when I played
grand theft the second,
third or one eye after a
day of just killing nonstop,
I'd walk outside and just feel weird,
you know.
But at least I knew it
was still a video game.
Brian, there was some images that somebody
posted in the Duncan Trussell thread,
um,
on the Rogan board about some,
another new technology that was
akin to the nvidia technology.
That looks absolutely insane. I believe
it's from Activision. If he can find
that, if you could pull those images
up because what they're doing,
the virtual is going to be like
really intense. I can't wait.
But that robot pussy though. Yeah,
the robot, the physical robot pussy,
the physical carbon based,
you know,
artificially created robot.
Like what's her face?
What was that girl's name
and blade runner. Who was,
uh, uh, Daryl Hannah. Yes.
That looks crazy,
dude.
I met Daryl Hannah in 1994 at canter's
Deli in La and she was so incredibly
normal. Like just a normal chick
hanging out with her friends.
Her friends were totally
normal and it was, it was a,
for me it was a very
educational experience because
I never thought that some
woman who was first of all an
attractive woman, second of all,
a super famous slash. S yeah,
super famous actor. Right.
And she could be with a
couple of her friends.
I think it was two guys and another
girl and I could be with a couple of our
friends and they were sitting next
to us and invited us to talk to them.
Just engaged us.
Like they were talking,
they were doing some game where your name,
the state and a what's the
capitol or what's the state motto?
That's what it was with the state
model and they were like engaging us,
can I come on and help out? Like we like
they were like friendly, super friendly,
like any normal person who you could sit
next to if you were in a booth by you
know. And that was cool.
It was really cool. It was,
it was really cool because it was like,
oh these, these like movie star people.
They're just fucking people, man.
They're just so fucking people that uh,
someone turns a camera on too.
But like that's not going to
happen when we all fuck robots
and the robots are going to know all
the answers. Anyways, her character,
blade runner,
Sacramento,
her character in blade runner
was fucking bad ass dude.
She was the number one robot for
that crazy little below that movie.
Oh that movie was so fucking amazing in
that movie was bad ass because that's
Sean Young chick. She was hot
too. God Damn, she was hot too.
Not just hot but like hypnotic.
There was like something about her like
look with her hair and everything and
there was like a,
there's a perceived innocence or
something like that to her as this robot
character that was just brilliant man.
And my memory is going to shit dude.
When I was running the all time,
great move when I was younger,
I got a weird job with Sean Young
and I can't remember it now.
You got a job with her, like some
weird movie, I can't remember.
And you know what happened to her man?
She kind of went off the rail.
What happened to her? She went off
the rails. She got it. It was too,
too much pressure.
I think being a famous movie star,
it's gotta be so it'd be in a famous
guy like you or is it a famous artists?
You're famous kind of for being crazy.
You can and you know the amount of like
mainstream TMZ type pressure you get is
very nonexistent or minimal and just
enjoy it. You enjoy it and it just,
you just like, but that Tom Cruise
Shit, right? Like where she was at,
she was at that Sean Young was in like
all of it. That's her name, right?
She was in like that movie. Kevin
Costner. Right. Who was that moving?
She said a gang of fucking
movies, man. She was a big time.
More pressure for women because it's like
you have a window to just do all this
shit and then you have a window to do
all this shit in and there's a freak out
of being this one person that all these
people were focusing on that it's so
completely unnatural. You are a complete,
you're, you're supercharging your system.
It's like putting a blower on a Mustang
and revving the engine much higher than
it's supposed to go the fuck away from
actresses, Bro. Like that's, that's a,
I would never generalize
like that because I've,
I've met like a lot of really cool
actresses that I love being friends with,
but as far as like friends, friends
is fine. I don't want to date anybody,
anybody's anything like me.
I don't want to date anybody who
is even remotely as crazy as I am.
What I'm saying.
So when I dated a chick that she's like,
you got to quit the podcast. I'm like,
that's sort of like fuck you bitch.
But then also like that's sort
of a good instinct, but you know,
there's people that it works out like
Thompson girl and his wife Christine
Deposits Kate. Do you
know, you know Tom Scar,
hilarious standup comedian and
his wife is fucking brilliant.
Like a really funny, I got
married and they're happy
and it works. I got to finish
telling you about the Mexican comedian
cause he's just brought us. Okay. Um,
I love what you're drawing right now,
by the way. My best drawing idea.
Um, so I told you I met the
greatest comedian ever in
Mexico. It's not possible.
I'll tell you and you fucking tell me.
Okay.
So I'm fucking my Mexican girlfriend
and it's not like she's joking with me.
She's almost nervous to tell me this.
It's like we're fucking,
and she's drunk and she's like,
I have, I have a little piece.
Like she was super nervous, nervous
that was never resolved. Yeah.
So I'm going to resolve it right
now or okay. It was never resolved.
You're correct. It was never resolved.
And, and I'm analyzing the Sh, I'm like,
was she joking?
No,
because she was super nervous to even
tell me we've fuck. And I'm like,
is that for,
is that, is that for real?
Is that it? Like she falls
asleep. I fall asleep. She's,
she's out. She's a drunk. We fucked,
she's out. And I'm like, this am I gay?
Did I just fuck a hermaphrodite?
I don't sleep at all.
The next morning she has to get
up early to go to work. I go, Hey,
remember that thing you said last night?
She's like, what? She's like, you know,
you said something last night.
And she's like, I gotta go.
She like runs out and I'm like,
Whoa, no closure, no whatever.
And I had three or four days
left in Mexico, you know,
and I was like,
I need to find out if I'm gay now.
This should be on vice. It's just not,
why haven't you like written this?
Cause I'm telling you right now.
So then, uh, every day, so we fucked
like every night until I left.
And every night she always says,
turn the lights off. Never.
These lights are always leaves a socks on.
And the chef dude feet won't walnut and
won't let me finger her because of the
pain
as well. I got the paint on
my hands, paint, paint. So
I'm scrubbing and I go, look,
they're clean tonight. She's like, no,
no, don't think it just fucking me.
And I'm like, wow, is it a thing
that comes out like this alien time?
There's so many questions.
I go, I go, hey, that thing,
the extra piece was that a joke?
She's like, and her face turns red,
like don't bring it up. And I'm like,
I'm with a fucking hermaphrodite.
Wow. This is crazy. And you didn't go
down on it, right? You didn't ever go? No.
I went down it, dude. I went searching
Bro. I wanted answers. You know,
I tried to go deep. I tried to get the
answers. So son never got the answer.
No closure. Lucky dude. You gotta do
what you gotta do in certain situations.
Just kind of back out. This is
cutting your losses. This is,
this is a two months ago, but you
really liked her. I really liked her.
Still Talk to her.
I just can't stop thinking about her.
She just doesn't want to talk about that.
She doesn't want and I accept it now.
I love it now. I love
that she's a guy, but she,
it doesn't sound like she has a guy.
She's a hermaphrodite.
Did her pussy tastes like pussy?
It's delicious. What, what does it,
what does it feel like? It feels
different. Like guacamole. No.
When you're actually having sex. No, it
feels when you make it, it felt great.
You know, she does. She has a wonderful
vagina. She's a great girl. Okay.
Didn't you say something like
on your podcast that, uh,
she was disconnected with sex though?
She was a little, she was a weird,
she's a weird chick, you know? Okay. But
what do you, what are you saying though?
That if this is what I'm saying? So
this is two months ago, no closure.
And in the two months I've accepted
that she was a guy or has male parts,
no problem. Wow. Was, uh, and she,
she avoids the thing and
she's texted me last night.
She goes, hey, you know that little piece
I told you about? And I go, yes, yes.
Finally closure. She
goes, I was joking. I go,
this is why she's the best comedian to
fucking drop a line of like that on a
dude and tell the punchline two months
later, okay, while he's racking his brain,
I was like,
let me fucking genius comedian.
You tell a joke that has a fucking
punchline. Two months later, oh my God,
that is one possibility.
Another possibility is she decided to
tell you that it was a joke because you
were pressing the issue and you
wanted to talk about a lot. I dropped.
That was the best way for her.
Do you understand that though?
He very well could have
been at hermaphrodite.
Not that there's anything
wrong with a hermaphrodite.
Joe's not like when heard some sort
of a chromosomal test. He just,
she told you something and you're
right and you declared to the greatest
community. Never. Or maybe
it was a hemorrhoid. It could
have been hemorrhoid. Sh,
listen, assessed. You can get a sense.
Listen guys, the ones that pop out,
when her little Dick
went into my dick hole,
it was the most amazing feeling
I've ever felt in my life,
but we just hit a low point.
She easily could be at Hermaphrodite. Just
didn't want to talk about it. Yeah, I,
that's a good way to say I was just
joking. How do you deal with people?
This is a good question for you that say
they don't listen to you, but they do.
Yeah. They got all this into your
podcast. That's okay. But they know,
but they do and they like, I don't care.
You know? Know if you want to listen.
Listen, if you don't want to listen,
don't listen. Because I'm thinking,
do you want to tell me you don't listen?
You're the doing it once.
You're either trying to inform me like
I don't know what you do. Well, no,
just being normal or you're
being dismissive. You know?
It's possible that you could say it
like in a way that like David Show,
I don't listen to your podcast.
Right, right. Okay. You know
where you're like, whoa.
Like, I wouldn't waste my time
listening to you, but here's the thing.
I talked about this on my show
and I'm thinking, did she hear it?
And so that's why she called
me. Yeah, but she doesn't,
she doesn't like follow me on Twitter
or Facebook or any of this shit and she
really,
you know,
well it sounds like it was a very strange
thing for you and almost indicative of
like life itself, whether it was
like itself has never perfect.
Whether it was a joke or not,
whether she really forgot to tell
me the punchline or like whatever,
whatever the case,
I accepted it well except Joe again is
does definitely nothing wrong with that.
But that's not the funniest
comedian on the face.
Come on Joe to someone pretty
soaked up though. You're having sex.
What if it's most likely an excuse?
What if your walls up but
it's not most likely a Joe?
What if your wife just out of tonight?
Just all fucking totally.
Seriously. I used to be a guy and
you're like, what are you talking about?
And then she didn't tell you the truth on
month later. That's pretty funny. Well,
that's a long, it could be. I
guess it could be funny. You know,
if you're the right guy and she was the
right girl and she said it the right way,
I guess it can be fun. [inaudible]
go. I never ever told David Show God.
It also could be that she's lying to
you if fishes like to talk about it.
And she really is something
like a hermaphrodite. It's
possible to dude. I mean,
unless you're going to go in Novia
if you're listening out there baby,
don't say her name. Just it's sweetheart
in Spanish. Oh, there you go. Beautiful.
I mean Novia um, if you're listening,
I hope you're not lying. Listen,
it doesn't matter man. I hope
it wasn't a joke. Listen,
you're not looking to have a
family, are you? I can't wait to,
I started looking at how a family,
right. I'm starting to think about, uh,
having kids without the wife
part. Well, like adopting or, uh,
or I'm freezing my sperm and doing the
whole surrogates or whatever. I Dunno.
Just freeze the baby. I think I'm
starting to think about having a family.
But you know, like I said, gay or not gay,
I hang out with a lot of dudes and so
like critter who I hang out with all the
times like fuck you get a girlfriend,
I'm going to have to have a girlfriend.
And it's like,
well that's cause then we hang out in
the logic is that because we hang out all
the time. So I said, why don't we
just share? You could get Monday ones,
they'll get Tuesday, Thursdays,
such a snapper seconds.
You automatically offered up the
first three days you could get money,
you could get the pee hole.
I'll take the be whole.
Ah,
come on Joe. Be So many women
right now. They're so angry. No,
we'll find a podcast is, I don't think
I would have a problem. By the way,
kitty had a pussy boner. I don't
think. I don't think it would if she,
if she act like a girl, she
was beautiful. Such a pussy.
Brian can even get hard for the grandma.
Come on. I'm that puts it
out. Like if I, I mean,
if somebody came out through
him and cleaned up for you,
but listen on the line is you are enjoying
the experience until your perception
exactly who she was and had a whole male,
female paradigm shifted.
She became this oddity to
you like damaged goods.
This, no, this was it, right? Well,
this is the thing I need a
second and this is for like,
I didn't like Avocados growing up. I love
it. I love him now. It took me a second.
It took my mom's like, eat
this. I go, oh, it's green.
It's probably tastes like a watermelon.
It tasted like shit. I love Guacamole now.
Uh, I had Moonee Sea Urchin for the first
time. I was like, this is disgusting.
It's my favorite food now. It
took me a second. I get to China,
the girls have to thin mustaches.
I go, what the fuck is that?
Because they don't care about
waxing and bleaching. I go,
that's gross because it's not normal to
me. I'm the in China for three months,
sort of into it like it now. Um, I'm
starting to have sex with Arab women.
They have Harry acids. Whoa. Grossed out.
Want to puke sort of into it now.
Just give me a second.
You've got a little dick
inside your pussy. Gross.
Gimme one month to adjust.
I'm from America.
I was born in Los Angeles. I live in
Western society. I'm not used to dicks.
I'm not used to Harry acids. I'm
not used the mustaches, but just,
I'm openminded give me a second to just
open wider and accept your mustache.
Your hairy ass. You're a dick in
your pussy. Just give me a second.
I'll eat the avocado.
I'll eat the sea urchin I at.
You know, like you weren't like
avocado. Avocado tastes like shit.
I'm never going to eat it again. It
grew on you. It took a second. You know,
I hated it.
I spit it out.
I just realized it was just a texture
issue that the actual taste of it was
fairly bland when in fact it has a lot
of health benefits and you want candy.
You want, you want watermelon, you want
fruit that tastes good, you know? Well,
the problem is you find out about candy.
That's the real problem.
And you find out something that
gives you this drug rush. I mean,
kids that get high on sugar,
like if you've ever seen kids eat cake,
they turn into fucking demons.
They go running around me and they're
crying and crank that guy out there.
It's more candy than anybody. It gets
crazy. It's not a kid, but he is sort of,
but you know what I'm saying? It's
like it's a clearly a drug, right?
So of course they don't
want to eat guacamole.
Guacamole doesn't give them that drug.
Right.
They want that drug that comes from those.
I have a that,
you know those sophisticated do that,
those powders,
those fucking things that kids eat
where it's literally a tube of sugar.
There's like pixie sticks and crack
open the end and you get funded.
It's drama nerds, nerds,
rope crunches, sugar drug.
That's still get fun Dept.
So bad for you too.
They say that sugar is
just almost toxic sugars.
Just almost toxic for you.
I know, but like, like I'm saying like
all these things, you know, I
don't, what are you doing? Like,
have you ever been with
a chick with a real,
like a Middle Eastern girl with a
hairy, but yes. And what did you do?
You're like, yeah, well it was back in
the 80s right? People that hairy butts,
it was a normal thing.
So it's worse is when they have catfish
whiskers and in certain lights you can
see it and you're like, ah. It's like,
but see what we're doing now is
that that episode of Seinfeld,
when he finds the one thing wrong, like
the CIC has the big hands or whatever,
and it's like, you know, I had sex
with this girl, I go to the bathroom,
we had sex in the dark and I turned
the lights on to take a piss.
And I look out the bed and her head,
she has a hairy ass. I'm like that.
I'm going to Puke in the toilet
while I'm pissing right now.
And I go just slow down.
Just except that it's someone
from another culture, you know,
like women.
Oh,
I sleep with a lot of women where I'm
their first Asian and they do that. Oh,
you have no hair on your body. I go, yeah,
I'm Asian. Like we are not hairy people.
You know, like it's like being
with a girl. I'm like, cool, Whoa,
rude.
How rude.
It's interesting how porn has completely
triumphed in the area of a pubic
dressing, but it's back. It's coming back.
Little coming back
contrarianism for the most part,
people prefer a groomed area.
It's because HD,
you know it's an ill,
maybe it was before that there was some
trimming done before that they want to
hire the bumps. What was,
because pornography became
like really prevalent, right?
That's what it is. Pornography became
really prevalent and then along the way,
like people started like looking at the
aesthetic of male balls covered in hair
that creeps all the way up
to your ass hole. Right?
And girls with giant crazy bushes that
go to the inside of the thighs and they
just decided to make alterations
on porn and then people,
whether they admit it or not, right. I've
massively affected by pornography. Oh,
of course.
And then the shift happened where,
I mean there's a good percentage
of the population of this country,
at least that trims their hair basically
based on the aesthetic that porn
established. Right?
Definitely. Right. Yeah.
It's weird because it's an untalked
about thing. It's an undiscussed thing.
It's a denied thing. It's like
it's a darkness that we just like.
Meanwhile they're getting billions of
hits every day. I'll watch or my shit.
Well,
I have to trim it too because it also
gets caught in the hair and my balls gets
caught in my cup like,
and if you're doing Jujitsu shifts,
getting along when you're bald here,
head stuck in your asshole here.
That's never happened. So it makes
like a dreadlocks. Dreadlocks. Yeah.
That's not good. You need
to better hygiene and that
you need better standards.
You need to not let it get them
to that wall. Joe, because I've
been naked around lots of different men
in different countries because of prison
or whatever. It's like,
yes, when I, when I'm,
when I was homeless here in America
and I was showering at 24 hour fitness,
then I'm like in a giant shower
with a bunch of men and like, yeah,
for the most part you look the
off for a second and you're like,
well people shave their shit.
It's like,
okay, cool. Then I'm in prison in Japan
and I, you know, it's a bath culture,
it's not a shower culture. And I
looked down and I'm like, Oh wow,
these guys don't shave their shit at
all. Well first of all, porn in Japan,
it's pixelated,
so you never really see anything anyways.
They pixelate genitalia or pubes the
whole area, just the whole ocean.
But they don't,
they don't shave their shit down there.
So their pubes are the same pubes
that grew from when they were a kid.
So they have beards, they're pubes
are longer than their dicks. Mike,
could I get out of the bathtub? I'm, you
know, I keep my shit tight, you know,
and I get,
get out of my Dick and balls hanging
out and then these guys come out and you
just see a black beard with like a
red dot with the tip of their Dick.
And you're like, oh, it looks like
a cute like homeless guy, you know?
But yeah, those things are all informed
by pornography. They don't watch in Japan,
they don't watch American pornography.
So of course they don't shave this shit.
The Bush is coming back.
What's fascinating though,
that it sort of gets us to,
I would imagine that Bush is coming back.
I'm out on the front line.
I'm telling you it's coming back with it.
But like look,
been bell bottoms coming back. No, but
it's back, right? Oh yeah, definitely.
I mean the almost like
I'd say five years ago,
every girl I was with had no hair or
like at tiny thin strip of whatevers.
Uh,
now almost all girls have some kind of,
probably heard the crabs were going
extinct and they got sad and I say,
have the crab growing in the
crowd. Cyclical. You know,
how come everybody doesn't want to
the crabs to live? They want to save.
Like would I love seafood?
I love Krista.
You know the ones that grow in your
Bush? Yeah, I eat those crabs like Daryl.
Hannah eats the lobster and splash
little little tarter sauce. A
little, uh, you know, cocktail sauce.
[inaudible] going to red
lobster right after this.
What's it like hanging
out with Dan at work?
Cause I know you guys are friends man,
and that's I,
I loved them and they must
be very interesting too. Do
you ever paint with them?
Yeah. Okay. First of
all, I love those guys.
Do you know who Dan word is? I love them,
but I don't love one of the new songs.
They got some new song, you know, they're
just going for it, doing everything.
There was that, fuck you in
the ass song. I was like, okay,
what are you doing man? What
the hell is this? It's great.
I like some of his
really early or shit too.
They did some really
interesting early stuff.
But do you hang out with a lot of
artists in general comedians? Okay.
So comedians or artists, comedians have
a few friends that are artists, artists,
artists, artists, chefs.
Most people that are highly,
highly creative are sort of fucking
crazy. They're crazy. Crazy as fuck.
And then, and then you try
to like do normal shit with
them and then you're like,
why are they doing this? Oh yeah.
Cause they're fucking crazy.
What makes them tick?
Every comedian that I know is
out of their fucking money one.
And I love Ninja and
I love Yolandi Ninjas.
One of probably the most
creative people I like,
he'll do a song and like he goes and then
the park was like this and he'll sing
every part of the song and he goes,
and then the music video
is going to go like this.
And then he'll act out everyone's part
in the music video and what the lighting
is going to look like
in down to the costumes.
And there's going to be a lion and this.
And did you,
do you ask for this or does this just
like happen in the middle of the Congress?
He goes, he goes, can I tell you like
a quick story? And does it do it?
Do it in his accent. You were about
to, Oh, I get bailed out of it. No,
I can tell you a quick
story about a set of,
they're the best as he can do a perfect
American accent and not like a gangster.
He was like, you heard Jim
Jefferies. Hey Dave, how's it going?
Jim Jefferies, a Australian comedian
has the most eerie American accent.
Really? He does an American guy and
you're like, yikes. It's too good.
It's like too good.
Right?
They can do us apparently way easier
than we could do them because we're
speaking normal. Sure. That's the case.
And I ain't get a might.
What is normal?
Can you decide somewhere along the line
that your way of talking is better than
mine?
Yes.
And the way that you do that
is the language of English
is spoken in Australia,
England, England, America, and
people make fun of Crocker.
They do the Crocodile Dundee but England.
And then you take someone who,
you take a Japanese exchange student who
doesn't speak English and you go learn
English.
What are they gonna do?
They're gonna listen to
dial down American movies.
They can understand Americans.
They can't understand British people.
They can't understand Australians.
They're like,
I don't what we speak
normal like normal people.
That's ridiculous.
Everybody in England who
grows up in England knows
how to understand people from
England. Everybody in America,
everyone in [inaudible].
Glenn can understand us.
We can't understand them.
That's interesting. A thick, thick
British accent. Give me a fucking break.
I'm like, that is interesting. It goes,
Hey, what did you just say? He was like,
oh fucking doors and I'll be like,
but if you were living there, you
would understand. I'm pretty clearly,
if you were in his neighborhood,
we're speaking proper English.
Joe.
I like slang. I'm not, I'm not like this.
I'm not like trying really hard to like,
so what we did is basically the
Brazilian Jujitsu of English.
We took the original Japanese
English and we made it more bad ass.
What's an extra guard?
Submissions and she'll come.
How come when they have
like some British movies?
Sometimes they've got to put fucking
subtitles on that shit because you don't
know what the fuck you got me,
man.
I get offended if they have movies
like snatch and they put the subtitles.
I get offended. Like I want to be
trying to figure that concentrate. Well,
I do when I interview fighters,
when I've, I've had, uh, Paul Kelly,
he's a gentlemen, I've had an interview
in the UFC. I'm Michael Bisping,
sky from Manchester, right? These
guys have incredible accents.
Bisping has gotten much better
at speaking in like a more clear,
he slows it down a little bit, right?
But English people and a Irish people,
they talk faster. They have a faster way
of combining the words together. Right.
I had a fucking guy come up to me
and I had a conversation with a
dude in Belfast, Northern Ireland
were getting drunk at a bar.
There was a UFC there and just me and
Eddie Bravo went down to this bar and we
said, let's just tie one on with these
Belfast people. And I think, um, um,
day bishop was probably there too,
right?
Who's the local comedian
that we did a Gig with?
This fucking dude was talking to me.
I didn't have a clue as to what
he was saying. We were hammered,
right? And he was telling me how it fight
it heal the basic tenant or the basic,
uh, uh, script was, I'll fight any
man. Right. He was just telling me,
letting me know he'll fucking
fight anybody. You know, it was,
I'll fight any of mine, chuck it out
to la aim. Hey, he made high capital.
Don't cat fight. Handyman
have fight any man. This,
I barely could understand him.
It was like this crazy game I was
playing like staring into his eyes and
struggling
and his word, and this is like the shit
everyone always wonders about, right?
You got, um, you got the dude that's
the jacks from sons of anarchy.
You got all these actors that have that
accent, right. How to fight any of mine.
But then they're in movies and TV
shows speak, or when they do songs,
accent just magically disappears and
then they're back doing the interview and
it comes back so they could turn it off.
They could turn that
shit off.
Now when they're drunk in a bar and not
some dude who actually lives in Belfast
to some local boxer,
I was ready to throw down and fight any
man for what he fight me. Oh Fuck Ya.
They want to fight those people.
We were in Belfast, right?
You're driving it like the fund.
They have these cars.
He's cop cars that have
bulletproof windows. Right.
These giant metal plates and bomb proof,
like shielding all over the car,
wrecked their cars are designed.
The cop cars are designed to absorb bombs.
Pull up, pull up some pictures of them.
Belfast, Northern Ireland, a cop, cars,
bomb protection. They like to fucking
party. It's a different kind of a world.
I mean they went through
some crazy fucking shit.
They went through a crazy war like
fairly recently. Right between, you know,
essentially people that are
right next door to them.
Right. Joe, I got to ask you a question.
Okay. David's, I like being scared.
I was like,
I like thinking about how I'm going to
fight myself if guys were trying to rape
me. I like doing a podcast. Something
that I've never done challenging myself.
I like trying stand up
something I'd never done before,
so I like being scared and challenging
myself to never been in a professional
fight. I've used to fight all the
time when I was a kid. I'm 37 now.
I haven't been in a real
fight in over eight years now.
If I wanted to have one like shitty
pro undercard fight,
how much training would have to do?
You'd have to see him a lot. A
lot like for a year, years, years.
He wanted to be safe. If you wouldn't
want to be safe, you, oh, here's a thing.
You're not in shape right now. You
don't have totally not in shape. Okay.
Do you do any kind of a sport jerked off.
It allows you to move aggressively.
You're in a lot of trouble. How old
are you? 37 you're going to get hurt.
Don't do it. I'm definitely going to get
hurt. No, no, no, no, no, no. Listen man,
this is, there's a romanticism that
people have about getting hurt.
I have no help you. I have no problem
getting to change your thought process.
Do you understand this? Like it's going
to change who you are as a human being.
Like you don't understand the head trauma.
If you've had,
I've been hitting my head my entire life.
I bet you've been really love your
head trauma. You've been really lucky.
Wasn't shit. I bet you have. I believe
you. But it all works still. Yeah,
there could be at any point in time
it could be the tipping point and head
trauma is just no joke and any
unnecessary head trauma, right,
that you want to introduce into your
life I always think is a terrible idea.
And what I know is if there's
a guy was 37 years old,
any martial arts training I do anymore,
well I don't even spar.
I didn't even kick her off
spar. I do Jujitsu, spar,
but I won't kickbox bar because it's
not worth it. You listen to me, man,
you only can get hit a certain amount
of times in your head and if you think
it's like cute to go out there and have
an MMA fight. No, I don't think it,
cause you want to experience it. It's,
it's fucking dangerous. I know, I know.
I'm most likely not going to win.
I know I'm most likely going to
get the shit kicked out of me.
But you don't want that man. I'm
telling you. I understand that.
You asking me that he's
could easily rate me.
I would like to be able to be not
going to beat that guy. You're not.
I met that guy like I was too big.
He's too big. I've got a guy like that.
You're going to have to become some
sort of a black belt in Jujitsu.
You're going to have to be
able to wrestle him too.
I appreciate the concern for the head
trauma cause I've had been extremely
damaged in my head before. I've had
been knocked out all that shit. Yeah,
it's not fucking awesome.
I've been knocked out where I
wake up and I don't know who I am.
Like that kind of shit.
So I'm not under any misconception of,
it's like going to be like a cake walk or
anything, but I'm just saying too many.
Will you train me? No Way. No Way.
I don't want to be a part of it.
It's too many variables. Play
me, bro. Here's, here's a
bunch of the variables. Okay?
You're in shape. First of all, you don't.
You got to have to pick a guy, right?
And you're going to have to
pick a guy that's commensurate.
I love saying that word. It makes
me feel sad. What does that mean?
It means like similar, like
Google, the same level.
I want to fuck the guy bigger than
me. Okay. What are you doing man?
What are you trying to get hurt for?
You trying to be a hero. No, I don't.
I just want to, I don't look, I know
a dude who lost his sense of smell.
He took a beating and lost his sense of
smell and it was just a one to head kick
combination. Okay. The most out
of shape and fat I've ever been,
the x factor. I'm was ferocious. Oh,
okay. I won't see luck with that shit.
I won't stop. That's not going to help
you out at all. Not even a little bit.
People think that being tough is going
to help you. I'm tough. I'm ferocious.
That's just going to get you hurt more.
That's just going to meet you.
You to take more punishment.
So then I'll tap out.
Then if I'm getting fucking the
shit kicked out of it. Okay,
well then what happens? You, you,
you got damage to your brain.
If you just tried bonded, she'll give
you fight a guy. Here's my, here's my,
my recommendation in this area.
If you really think about doing it,
if you want to do it and you
want the same kind of thrill,
you can get a very similar thrill from
doing a Jujitsu match or just getting
your butthole lick by old ladies. No,
cause that, you know, when you tap out,
it's your responsibility. But
the whole thing, things going on.
So you're telling me to stick
to just getting massages by men?
Well I just think that it's not to be
fucked with head trauma is not to be
fucked with people die man.
There was a kid in Ireland that died a
really recently in a rugby match. Right?
And he had had a,
he got knocked out to guests and needed,
he got knocked out again and
died. Well, here's the thing,
I know for sure I have a glass jaw.
Like if you hit me in my jaw,
I knock out my entire life. I'm Korean,
I have a thick head, we have big heads.
Right?
That's how you can tell the Asians apart.
Like Koreans usually have bigger
heads. Um, big moon pie faces. No.
If you see like a Chinese,
Japanese and Korean, we usually,
our heads are a little bit bigger,
right? I've been kicked, punched, like,
like I've had a lot of head trauma and
it all, for the most part still works.
My memory's going to shit a little bit.
But asides from that,
I can fucking for the most part function.
Okay.
And I could see if you're willing to take
this chance and possibly alter the way
your mind works if you're going
to be intelligent about it.
Cause you're an intelligent guy,
which you would want to do is dedicate
yourself to martial arts first before you
ever actually do it. And it was
Kinda, it's Kinda taking a long time.
You're going to have to learn how,
first of all, to defend yourself. And B,
you're going to have to
learn to be proficient in
something. Well, it's striking.
I have, my background is judo. I grew up,
I grew up doing judo and I know how good
are you? I was, I want a lot of awards.
What was your belt? What, what belt did
you get to green or something? Okay.
I didn't, I didn't get
my black belt, but I won.
I won every single judo match I was in.
Well, that list, why not an amateur?
I remember talking about,
I'm not a novice Joe,
I'm talking 15 years old was the last
time there's an understanding there.
Like what we know,
I wrestled in high school then I,
there was no touching in judo,
but I never lost,
I wrestled in high school and I didn't
do any grappling again until I went to
Jujitsu, which is like almost 10 years
later. Right. And, uh, I remember,
I remember it like instantly can
right back to me because your,
your body develops as a young man.
Understanding how to pin someone,
understanding how to grapple and get
gable grips and how to use your hips to
sprawl.
You kiss just comes back to you.
And I think that like
having that background,
especially at that age 15 that's big.
Learning something and
getting really good at it.
Where are you competitive
at it when you're 15 right?
That's like such a developmental period.
It becomes like sort of a part
of who you are as a person.
But the thing with me is I, my
bones break easy. Oh Jesus. So I've,
and I just fucking do it.
I just quit after whatever.
Like I broke my collarbone in
judo, I quit, I played baseball,
I broke my collarbone, I quit, I played
football, I broke my ankle, I quit.
It's like anytime I break a bone, I'm
like, okay, that was that. You know. Well,
it's not hard to break your ankle or your
collarbone doing any of those things,
whether it was judo or football
or baseball. That sounds in line.
I mean it might not even be that you're,
your bones break easy.
It might be that you're just
a little bit too ferocious.
I hugged the shit out of, you
know, but you know what I'm saying?
You're like going for it.
No,
I really like when I tell
people interested themselves,
my, my parents were like,
you have to wear, my dad was like, you
have to learn some kind of martial art.
You're Asian, you have to. Yeah. I
was like, we, you know, we, we were
not into sports. Loosely set the bar.
We had long hair. We fucking
did. We listened to heavy metal.
We didn't care about
anything. My, you know,
it's like when a guy has
three sons and he's like, yes,
they're going to watch sports with me.
Whatever we did in fucking give a shit
about, we were nihilists we'll be like,
we don't care about shit. And why
is that? I don't know what happened.
We like, we would, we would go to school,
like my dad would take us a sack full of
balls and just pour it out in front of
us. On the weekends ago. What do you
guys want to play? Softball, baseball,
a kickball, handball, football basket.
He'd have every ball and be like,
what do you guys want to do? And we're
like, nothing. We don't want to do any,
I don't know. We just,
we were just very like,
we don't care about anything.
We don't,
when you look back on like what
turned you into who you are today,
this is sort of wild dude.
Do you have any one thing that
like stands out as being the, the,
I don't give a fuck. There's not
one, there's not one incident,
but it's a combination of racism,
uh,
humiliation and like, just
never getting laid, you know?
So just lack of good experiences
and a lot of bad experiences.
Just unbelievable amount of anger,
you know,
like going to a school where everyone
makes fun of you for being Asian.
Go into someplace where every girl rejects
you and then within your own family,
having this insane sex drive where just
everyone just catches me jerking off all
the time. Like just the, uh,
I was sleeping when you're really
young. I mean the humiliation, like,
oh my God, my mom just saw the tip of my
dick hard. But don't you think though,
when you were like really young,
a really stressed out and really fucked
up that that's almost like a natural way
to blow off the steam. You're like, dude,
who are troubled almost always check off
a lot. Yeah. You know, I, I don't know.
What do I, what, what am I
doing surveys? No, I'm not that,
there was no census attached to anything
that I've said here. I'm just talking.
No, no, no. I know, but you're right.
Like I would go home and I'd just
be full of aggression and I'm like,
and I just wasn't good at sports, so I'm
like, I don't even want to try this shit.
But then when they told me in football,
you could hit people cool. And then like,
yeah, I don't even know how you're
angry. You wanted to hit very angry.
And the thing with judo is I, that's
another thing that my parents made me do.
I didn't want to do it,
but it's like I also didn't
like people throwing me around.
So when we got into it I was just like,
I don't care if this guy's a
higher belt than me, whatever.
Like I'm not going to let
him pinned me down. You know?
Like as soon as he starts winning,
I'm going to go like I just went there,
I'm going to go fucking crazy
and well what you should do.
I became a pride of my Dojo. They sent
me to all the tournaments and I was like,
that was like the reluctant, like I don't
want to be here, but okay fine. I'm here.
I'm going to win the pride of your Dojo.
Yeah.
I won every like trophy thing for and
then I broke my collar bone. I was like,
okay, that's the end
of my collarbone. Okay.
Now my shoulders are a little smaller
cause I broke this one and this one. Wow.
So you don't have to call her bones break
in the video like this, right?
Really? Yeah, they, they,
they just healed next to the collarbone
snap and then there's no brace.
You can put on.
So you just hold your thing up and then
the bones just heal like this over each
other. Yeah. And so how much stronger
or weaker is it than they used to be?
I think they get stronger,
but my shoulders are a
little bit in there or, wow,
that is a weird man.
It could be worse though.
There's a lot worse shit that you can
break. Right? I'm not scared of pain.
Like I've been burned.
I've you sound like a guy was doing this
like interview thing for like a king of
the cage and routes. No, no, no. Like
patient care to pain. Pain is not like,
oh pay my whole like I'm not
gonna do something cause I
could get hurt. You know,
like that doesn't bother
me. You know, and I,
and I'm not scared to be humiliated
either. That what I worry about,
I worry about for people that don't have,
like an extensive background
in martial arts is head trauma.
You're not going to know how to get away.
You're not going to know
how to not get hit as hard.
You're not going to know how
to protect yourself. Judo.
All we do is for the first few months
of learn how to fall down. So I do.
That's good.
Jumping over someone and then tucking
into a role and all that shit like you
know, I know to fall down, I'm willing to
bet you get any hint. That's all right.
Right.
I mean it's just appreciate it.
I appreciate your concern and this is
something I'm probably not going to do,
but just wanted to throw it out to
see if what your thoughts on it.
I seen people take some serious punishment
and change them as a human being
changed the reality of their life. Right.
Impair their function. Right, right.
It's real. No, I know that I've seen
it happen not just from men and May,
but I have a friend who got hit in the
head with a golf ball and he wasn't the
same for almost a year, so he said
like six months. He was fucked. Fuck.
Cause every day massive headaches and
it depression and that can happen.
Who hit the golf ball?
Some dude just,
he got hit with a line
drive right in this side.
Like fuck he's playing golf
or just sitting at his house.
He was on the golf course and I just
don't have an errant ball hit him in the
temple and he got fucked up man.
He went down hard,
just like totally knocked unconscious
fucked up for a long time.
So what I'm one of my, my point is like
that can happen from a kick to man,
that can happen from a knee.
You can be diving for a takedown and some
guy comes up with some flying knee and
separates your fucking vertebrae. Right?
It's nasty shit man. You can get really,
really hurt if you really want to do
it though. What I was gonna say is,
well you should do is make it a vice
thing. Have them follow you with cameras.
Start like a real training thing. How
then checking on you every couple months,
but do it in a way where you're not
going to hurt yourself, go to a gym.
Or was it that
you can minimize the amount of damage
that you take with intelligence? Right.
But actually learning some skills.
And so if you really want to do it back
on the show, if I'm in a wheelchair,
of course if I'm stuck,
I'll have you back on the show.
If you talked to me through a
thing in your neck gel like jet,
I've listened to you. It was all
right when it came to not doing MMA.
I'm not saying that
anybody should not do MMA.
I think that if you're
going to take risks,
it's ridiculous to take risks that have
in w within them the possibility of
massive trauma and,
and not do it correctly.
Like you could get knocked out.
Obviously. Look Anderson Silva,
who's the greatest mixed martial
arts fighter of all time, right?
And he's the master. He got knocked
unconscious. Janie buddy can
telling to me is complete common
sense, but there's no, but it's just,
it's you're making sense,
right? And, and the thing is,
it's you telling me they shouldn't start
like, oh man, Joe was talking crazy.
It's like you're being a good guy
giving me the wisdom of, you know,
all the stuff you've seen and learn.
Okay. Yeah, there is a, but, but uh,
it's weird, like I just got, um,
did you see the vice HBO series?
Yes.
It's just like suicide bombers,
you know,
pirates like all dangerous
shit. Right, right, right.
They asked me to be for season two,
one of the hosts and I just got the
assignment list of things, you know,
of places to go and it's every
single place I could die, you know?
And it's like,
there's nothing about that.
And I don't know what this says about me,
but there's nothing about that where
I'm like, oh, I'm scared of my life. Or,
you know, I'll go anywhere. I
don't give a shit, you know, so,
well then you're the perfect guy for
the job. Cause me, I'm at home going,
boy would want to be fucking David Show
right now. Well that's why when it,
when the things you
tell me about hurting myself, those things
don't, that's not a deterrent for me,
but I guess dying is dying.
You're just dead.
Listen man, being in a wheelchair
is, you're, you're traumatized.
I would never want someone like me doing
something to me that I could do to me.
I would never want someone planting a
fucking Shin on my head the way I know I
can do to somebody. Right? I would
never want someone kicking me in.
The body punched me in the face the
way I know I can do to somebody. Right?
I would never want someone
who knows how to strangle me,
strangle me the way I could do to me if
I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
So what I'm saying is if you are
going to engage in mixed martial arts,
you've got to get proficient at a
martial art in order to be able to
intelligently defend yourself. Cause if
you can't intelligently defend yourself,
someone who's good,
who's going to really fucking hurt you,
and there's not a goddamn
thing you can do about I am.
It's not going to be a fight,
man. Unfortunately, it's
going to be a fight. Right?
But in, unless you're find someone who's
a novice, it's not going to be a fight.
It's going to be a
slaughter. No. Unfortunately,
I'm better at defending myself
than being offensive. Like it's,
that's all nice and good. But if you get
a guy who actually knows how to fight,
you're fucked,
right?
If you're not careful and you go
in there and get some division one,
all American fucking puts you on your
back in three seconds and starts smashing
your face with elbows from an impossibly
strong body that's been throwing other
bodies around its entire life.
And you just thought you're being cute
because you're an artist who likes to
fuck chicks and you never
work out and you're like, oh,
I'm just going to go in there and
take an adventure. I'm like, fucking,
I'm modern day Joe. I'm getting harder
and you've gotta be careful, man.
I don't want you to just sweaty as fuck.
If you lick him, you'll get lighting.
It is grow ovaries.
If he drops a sweat in your mouth,
it's a dangerous thing you're, you're
involved in. I know someone who, you know,
you have to be careful and sure that
what you should do is take another,
if you really want to do
this, took another person
who's like you and say, Hey,
let's fight any year. Right?
And let's do it amicably.
Let's get together and let's,
uh,
let's what's both experienced this and
it'll probably make us a language of
other, more as we're steamy. What you just
described, it was gay sex a little bit.
I'll do this to you and you've
seen it too many times, man.
I've seen people who think they're
tough guys go in there and get,
I don't think I'm going to, I understand.
I don't think I'm going to go in there.
And you kind of described yourself as
being pretty ferocious and durable and
really good at judo and
the pride of the Dojo.
So although you might not think you're a
tough guy, you think you're proficient.
Well,
I,
I think I'm able to like protect myself
from like getting those things that's
all nice and cute. Like, I don't know.
You find somebody who actually
knows how to fight. Right? Right.
You don't know how to protect yourself,
just do it. You just shut the fuck up.
Seriously. I'm trying to help
the guy. It's just I just,
I've seen it too many times
and I'm acutely aware of
the possibilities and what
I can do is we're scared to go and it's
something I've already done now so I
know what it feels like.
I'm more scared to go in front
of audience and do stand up.
Then I think I would be to go and
fight someone. So ferocious fighter.
That's because you haven't done both?
If he did both,
you'd be way more scared of
fighting in fights before joy.
I've had the living shit kicked out of
me by like gangs and like a bunch of
people like I know what pain feels like.
It's not like,
like I know what it feels like to get
knocked out and then wake up a day later
and not know who I am. Like I've,
you know, I'm sure you do know that.
I also know that it's bad. Of course, you
know. Of course, I know that, you know,
I'm saying, man, I just,
I don't like when people get romantic
about it because it's a part of,
it's not a room. It's almost
like something, I like the
comedy thing, you know, I,
I've done it three times
now and it turned out good,
but I didn't go in there
with that. I was like, Oh,
I'm going to bomb and people are going
to boo me and this and that and I'm,
I'm prepared for that, you know?
But it didn't turn out that way.
But you know what? I'm good. Yeah.
I'm not going in there going,
I'm going to be fucking Eddie
Murphy. Like, you know, I
have,
I've never discouraged someone who wants
to actually be a mixed martial artist.
I've never discouraged anyone
who wants to ask me in alerting,
mixed martial arts,
taekwondo,
I've never just tried to
discourage anybody who wants
to do something dangerous.
But I just always say,
if you're going to do it,
just know as many variables as possible,
right?
There's always variables in a
live fight, right? You don't know.
You could get hit by the first punch
and you're just lights go out. Right.
Or you know, weird injuries.
Ha, weird things can happen,
but you got to be as prepared as possible
in order to be smart about it. Well,
that's what I would say the most
fighters retire around what age anyways?
It's completely different. I mean, here's
an interesting thing, Bernard Hopkins,
it's interesting because
it never existed before.
Bernard Hopkins is the
oldest champion ever.
How old is the light heavyweight champion?
And he's 48 and he's amazing.
He's still out boxing the shit
out of people and doing it.
Let's just say it's a thing of beauty.
I mean, he's a fucking artisan in there.
He has a craft. It's just like playing
a guitar or, or being a painter.
He's got a craft. He's
an artist at it, right?
He knows how to minimize the
amount of damage he takes.
It very rarely gets hit and he
knows how to box the fucking ears.
All the young whippersnappers
but he's 48 so,
but he takes care of himself,
right? He's eating right, right.
He's working on a regular basis. It
never allows himself to get out of shape.
He's been fighting forever and he's
got these skills developed over a long
period of time series. Yeah.
I mean if I did the shit,
I would treat it totally serious.
I wouldn't go in there fat.
I would train my ass off for how
long if you like, I don't know.
Why would you want a year? If you could
do a year, you could get a lot done,
but you would have to make sure
that you were matched up ethically.
That someone is really a nice person, like
matches you up with another guy who's,
you know,
at least you have a chance.
I know you say you want to go against a
bigger guy. Just someone you're sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. No, she Yoshi. Why
would you say that? The friend?
Fuck yeah. I don't know. I
wouldn't want to fight Yoshi.
Yoshi just got that to the death.
Look in his eyes.
Yoshi might take things into the basement.
I might,
they might evoke the dark Lord. You might
see some fucking hell fire in his eyes.
Oh Man. I just, I get sensitive about
the one issue I don't like to preach,
but there's one issue that I get sensitive
about and is that the frivolous ation
if that's a word,
I'm not frivolous head impact.
Well, I'm not frivolous.
Like Joe, I'm telling you,
I understand repaired to get hurt.
I know that shit.
I know my break something or I
might get knocked out unconscious.
Like I know that I'm not like saying,
yeah, it's going to be fine. Whatever,
you know I'm not frivolous thing at all.
I understand.
I'm just willing to take what you're,
you know, you're, you're in this world.
I'd thought there'd be a
good guy to talk to him.
Yeah.
Well if you are really going to dedicate
yourself to and you want to do it as an
experience, I think in a year
is a good amount of time.
I think that I, in the same way I started
thinking about maybe adopting a kid,
I just thought also maybe I should fight.
I would say over the fight
first. You know, that seems
like less of a commitment,
right? You know, if you get fucked up,
hopefully a body shot so many hooks
you to the liver tap out immediately.
I'm just going to stick with the
hermaphrodites. What have you got?
A hermaphrodite pregnant.
I mean,
it's a very likely she could still get
pregnant then the baby could suck the
Dick on the way out. We, we should,
let's look that up.
Can I hermaphrodite get pregnant now?
Well, I mean, if I was a,
I think most hermaphrodites the
Dick is above their vagina. Right?
And I think most inside inside,
and I think it's just like half
the size and it really doesn't,
even if it gets hard, it's not like
a Dick and just look at it a little.
I think it's not functional either. Like
it doesn't now see, I wouldn't mind that.
If the girl's cool and shit, you
can, you know, it'd be cute rubber,
a little pussy Boehner
and be fun. Um, there's,
there's a porn star that has huge clear
tourists. I can't remember her name,
but like the dudes in the pornos always
suck her clit like it's a little penis.
Okay. Here's the question. Okay.
Here's the questions answered.
A survey suggests that functioning ovaries
are fairly common in the intersexed.
Pregnancy and birth don't happen,
but they happen.
Functioning testes are rarer,
but again,
not completely unknown functioning
ovaries and functioning testes, however,
plus functioning everything else.
Um,
I suppose I could propose one far
fetched scenario where it could possibly
happen, but as a practical matter,
it's not get out. It says so it set,
what they're basically saying
is that there's variables.
The same reason why there's
a hermaphrodite in the
first place is because he's
this weird variation they get.
There's a bunch of different levels of
that variation. It only makes sense.
I mean you think about people are
not the same. We're all different.
We all look different. We're all shaped
different. We're all different sizes.
It just makes sense that we would have
variations as far as our genitalia girl,
does she have a period
or does she just fart?
Great question. That's another
one you should have not said.
So He'd run those through the
Internet first. Before she told me
the punchline, Jeez, I really enjoyed this
last month and I was gay. I really did.
I was like,
that's what a punchline dude. It's a
fucking excuse. It's not a punchline.
Do you understand? You're trying to
rationalize it. That's a punchline.
This woman's got a dick up there. It's
okay though. Well, it's just a joke.
She's the greatest community.
Never Lol.
RFL Mao ladies,
if you're listening,
it's a fantastic joke to
pull on here and do it.
Just tell them that used to be a guy or
that there's an extra piece jumps right
off a fucking cliff and you're like,
that's why it's a next level of joke.
It's a joke.
Just level doing to your
thinking and correct.
And uh, yeah. My,
my mom is also like,
she came to Mexico for the show and
she's just letting me know, you know,
my mom had three children. Me, both
my brothers, I'm in the middle.
We're all in our late thirties
now. No one's married. And
do you think that's how like a rebound
from the strict Korean way of being
raised?
Me and all my brothers are weird. We're
like weird. People always have that.
Like all of our cousins, they're
all happily married. Have kids,
they have normal lives. Like I tell
them my stories and they're like,
Dave's weird uncle Dave.
He's,
you know, right. But I feel weird too.
I, there are people that are suppressed.
I think everyone's aware.
Yeah. I think talking like I think I'm
normal and I know that that sounds thieves
crazy. He does crazy shit. And he
thinks, I'm like, I think of the most
normal person because I just do,
I live like how I think
you're supposed to live.
And then I meet these people that just
do what society wants them to do and it's
crazy to me. And they withhold, they
live like fucking pussies. Well,
you didn't own beings.
Passionate followers.
We're naturally pattern following.
So we naturally follow successful patterns
of behavior because those have been
proven to be effective.
So all of our concerns and issues and
insecurities to sort of get ironed out in
advance by other people that are
successful. Right? So when we,
when we follow the society
pattern that's set up right now,
the society pattern is,
you know, get married, get
divorced, lose all your money,
get married, stay together, have
a family, get married, you know,
a [inaudible] and you know,
get married, be super happy.
There's a few different
possibilities that can happen to you.
It's a bunch of different ones, but you
have to follow the natural paradigms,
right?
If you don't,
there's something wrong with you
and people who are following them.
They don't want to be around
you like especially like wives.
I'm sure you have friends that have
wives that do not want David show.
Being around the hideous,
David chose talking about getting
his butt hole sucked out of his head,
his body by some crazy woman.
I got advice
people, but it's not for married
people. It's not for everybody.
My advice is for people who
don't want to be, like if the
giving advice,
you're giving out experiences that
you feel are very positive experience,
I like to go and people can
learn from them. Yeah. When
people go, oh, Dave's lucky.
He, it's like he won the lotto with
the Facebook shit and this, I'm like,
I've been successful at
everything I've ever done.
I've made tons of money doing art,
gambling. It's like, oh. So that,
that was all luck for people don't
know what the Facebook thing is.
Just in a nutshell,
just spell it out real quick.
That was something that I learned
from gambling that I brought over.
I had just gotten out of prison and
a guy named mark, uh, Sean Parker,
who started Napster, had, you
know, he's 23 or 24 at the time.
Maybe it's 26 but he was in his young
twenties and he'd already started a couple
of multimillion dollar companies.
None that really made any money.
Plaxo didn't make any money. Napster
got sued for, I think, $1 trillion.
So this was his next project and this
whole time he was a fan of my art.
He's like, Dave, I got to get
a painting from you. Like,
you're a sick fuck like me.
I need to get a painting from you,
but I'm being sued right now.
I can't afford it, this and that. And so
when Facebook came up, he's like, look,
there's this new social media site that
connects college kids. And I was like,
that sounds gay.
And he goes,
and we have some financial backing so
now I could finally pay you to do a
painting. And I said, or if you want,
if if, and he's, you know,
he's an innovator. He's
like, I'm going to fucking,
the shit is going to take over the world.
This, I'm going to change the world.
This is good.
If if you don't want,
then I could give you stocks
in the company and I needed
money because I needed
to pay my lawyers. I need to pay
all my ex girlfriend, my friends,
I need to pay everyone back. And I
said, I don't know about social media.
I was never on my space. I
was never on any of these
things. I said, you know what?
I believe in this kid.
So I took the stock stock ended up being
worth hundreds of millions of dollars.
So overnight that made me, I guess the
highest living paid artists in the world,
which is pretty cool.
But before that I was pretty
successful at everything else I did.
And uh, why do you think that is? Well,
I just came back from this conference in,
in Norway of the all the top chefs in
the world. So I'm like, this is cool.
I like this.
I'm in a new environment.
It was sort of like show of boarding
boarding didn't go, that's why I went.
David Chang who has Momofuku in New York
goes board and please come this year is
talking about guts about being brave
and you come and boarding. It's like,
are you kidding me?
I'm not going to fucking embarrass
myself in front of the top chefs.
I've been out of this game.
Like he's like, Dave, you
should go. And so I'm like,
what am I going to do? And I just started
thinking I want to start doing standup.
So Dave Chang was like,
Dave,
why don't you come and like you'll be
the first non shift that's been asked to
speak at a fucking chef conference of
600 of like the top Michelin Star chefs.
And I don't know these people, I get
off the plane and they're like, Dave,
we're going to eat at nomo tonight.
You know, and uh, or Nola, sorry,
I said it wrong. Fucking
retarded. He'll reading at Nola
tonight. I'm like, oh, Nobu.
And I'm, I'm like, oh, there's
a Nobu Nobu in Copenhagen.
Nola is the fucking number one voted
restaurant in the world like four years in
a row. Like, it's like an
eating experience. You've never,
the guy that runs a Nola,
Renee is a fucking like Picasso
of the cooking world. I mean,
just insane. Like, like he'll put
this in front of you and you're like,
what is this?
And it's like,
this is a rock that I just shit with
food that you would never believe.
And so I'm here with these highly,
highly successful people that are like,
you know, a fucking Darrio cine, uh, um,
fucking, I can't even remember all their
names. Alex had Taylor from Brazil. Um,
they all have the number one restaurant
in their city, you know, the guys in La.
And this for me, it's amazing
because Dave's like, you know,
we're not going to be able to pay you.
We can get you out here,
but you will never have to fucking wait
to eat at any of these restaurants ever.
And I'm like, I'll do it just
for that. And I get there.
And so I don't know who
any of these people are,
but they are the fucking
champions of the cooking world.
And so I got to hang out with
them for a week. And it, it's,
you once talk about following
patterns of success. I mean they,
first of all, they're all angry,
like an insane amounts of like,
this is the way you run a restaurant
and why they challenge everything.
They are fucking brave. They fucking
went for it. Like everyone said,
a restaurant is going to fail.
The chances of a restaurants thing
in business is not that good.
And who's going to want to eat a
fucking Taco that has Korean media?
Like you're, they're challenging the
norm. They're challenging society and,
and they're all crazy challenging
society with Tacos. Just, you know,
whenever you go to a
restaurant and you like,
well that's the thing is I went there
and I was like, I don't know. I don't,
I don't even know why I'm here.
So these guys are talking about what
do you mean you'd have to eat? No,
it was about next level food. Like
how does it was serious, right?
It's like what food is doing to the
conference conference. Yeah. Okay.
I thought you meant the restaurant.
Oh, well the restaurant was to eat,
but then the whole conference was like
the fucking shitty food we're serving in
public schools. Uh, like a guy that,
a speaker there was from Somalia,
his restaurant had been blown up like
three times and he keeps opening it.
So it was about all these,
it was sort of like on a serious topic,
like the state of food right
now with overpopulation.
And what that's doing to create
like dark snow and just, I'm like,
what the fuck am I doing here?
You know?
And it was super serious and they're
covering like real issues about food and,
and the world and this and that.
And then I just,
I just went on stage and started talking
about how everything makes me shit.
That's all I could do, you know?
And she tried to do stand up.
I did standup and it was amazing.
Like that's hilarious. Yeah,
it was fucking awesome. Like I was, I,
I puked before I went for
a walk and I was like,
the girl before me was a 10 year old
speaker that talked about how she changed
the way people eat in Africa,
offer offer blog. And I'm like,
I need to kill myself.
Oh my gosh.
I think she's 10 and she changed
the way they eat now. Yeah.
She started a blog about how
people are starving and, and,
and everyone's crying and clapping
and I'm like, Holy Shit. I was like,
I can't go up there and try
to sound like I'm a food guy.
And I just talked about things that
give you diarrhea. Well, I'm Asian,
you know, I, I grew up, man,
I'm Asian. I grew up in America.
I'm Asians aren't supposed to
eat lasagna then they, no. Why?
There's no cheese in Korean food.
There's not no,
there's no cheese in Korean food.
So you can't eat lasagna.
Thousands of years of Koreans eating rice
and soup and Korean, seaweed and shit.
Korea Poulenc wine. They come to America.
What did you say Brian? Korean poo wine.
What does that,
it's something in Korea that's a medicine
vice did a thing on it where they
take, uh, the poo of a seven
year old child. Oh, come on.
And they actually had a reporter
from vice that had to take it.
And I felt so bad for her. She was so
nice about it. She drank the poo wine.
I don't know about Korea.
I don't want to say this.
Basically she cut that off to it.
There's
no, there's no, you know, all the shit
that there's, that's part of American die,
like hamburgers, spaghetti, Tacos,
all this shit. This is all new.
You know, this is all new.
So your genetics are not set
up for cheese. So what WWE,
so my entire life I've had
irritable bowel syndrome. Wow.
Life my whole life.
A part of the anxiety is I'm going to
go talk to Joe Right now, live for,
I don't know, an hour or two hours,
whatever. If I'm getting nervous,
I have to shit like I what?
I'm going to make this guy live,
cut the thing so I have to run.
So that gives me more anxiety
and that adds to the pukey.
So did you cut dairy out of your diet?
I S I love Lasagna. I can't stop.
You know, that's just your decision.
You love design you more than you love,
not shitting yourself. I love comics
the same way you love comics. Okay?
But I grew up reading like
Calvin and Hobbes for, I
started with the funnies, the,
the newspaper, you know, like Garfield,
Calvin and Hobbes, right. All that shit.
And so I was obsessed with Garfield,
like eating Lasagna,
you know, I'm like, why? Why
does this cat eat? You know,
because I'm an Asian kid eating rice
and fucking Kimchi. I forgot about,
I don't know. I don't know what was,
I don't even know how to pronounce it.
[inaudible] you know, so let's
tag. I'm like, you know, and,
and I don't know what it is. It's like a
exotic foreign white people food thing.
And then my aunt brings it one day and
we eat the shit out of it. And I'm like,
no wonder Garfield loves it because it's
cheesy and it's got tomato sauce and
what does it do? It explodes out
of my ass. It's like poison to me.
I can't eat this shit. I can't
eat dairy. I'm lactose intolerant,
but it tastes so good. There's nothing
in Korean food that tastes close to that.
I mean, we have other delicious treats,
but nothing like that. So I'm like, look,
I told you,
but you were really willing to take
that just for the delicious taste.
You willing to just do it a shit
yourself. I do it even today. Now, I mean,
my eye, I've had irritable bowel syndrome,
so I've always looked it up on, on uh,
you know, web MD and
shit like that. How it,
there's no known cause for it,
but they think it's most likely stress,
you know? So, um, but wouldn't
it be dietary? Well it's,
it's, it's a combination.
I have the IBS from like the
nonstop stress and then also the,
the dietary part of it. So yeah, I
cut down a little bit on the dairy,
but the stress part,
a lot of it came from the gambling,
from all the taking all these insane
chances. Like I'll tell you like, oh,
I'm going to fight some crazy killer and
I might get my shit kicked in, whatever.
Like I'm cool, like out here, but
inside I'm like, oh my God, you know,
or we're going to send you to interview
some Somali pirates and they might chop
your head off, you know? Cool, no
problem. But inside I'm just shitting.
I'm just a fucking mess.
So I internalize it.
So as I've eliminated less
stress from my life, I've,
the IBS has gotten better, you know?
Jesus. So, so that's what I did.
My whole act on and the,
and you know when I Friends Harris
widows who writes for eastbound and down,
he does stand up to, and I
said, dude, what the fuck do
I talk about? And he goes,
anytime you do stand up,
like it's a fucking cheap
shot, it's a no brainer shit.
Stories always kills, you
know, so I went up and I, and,
and it did like the people
there were like, I was like,
all that food you guys serve me, makes me
shit. And you know, I turned it around.
I ended up talking about, you know, how
I'm in a different, um, practicing them.
But you know,
if you want to be successful,
if you're not focused in life
is to be like a family person.
But if you want to be the absolute
best of whatever your field is,
then you have to take chances. You can't
be a pussy, you can't be a follower,
you can't follow.
You have to break constantly and
challenge yourself and challenge the way
everything is.
You have to question things.
And it's scary because no one else has
done it. So shitting yourself, you're
challenging yourself. Well that, well
that is the joke part, but when it was at
its worst, I didn't leave the house. Wow,
that's so crazy. This is my diet
up. This is, this was my day. Well,
it wasn't just the dice.
Well, how of a variation did
you give your diet? Oh, did you ever cut
out gluten? Did you ever cut out dairy,
everything and just try to eat nothing
but meat and vegetables? Uh, I've, yeah,
I've done every different kind of like
I've tried nothing else. Uh, you know,
I did just protein stuff. I've
done, I've done different stuff.
But at the end of the day, it's always
the, the stress that gets to me. You know,
what stress feel like
I'm in therapy. Well,
I've been in jail a lot of times. The,
which means I did a lot of bad things.
So yeah, I used to like constantly
be looking over my shoulder.
So that's the stress. That was when I was
younger than the gambling. Every time,
every week I would put my entire life
savings on the line. So it's like, wow,
I'm in Vegas. Someone else's like having
a good time, going to a strip club,
whatever.
I'm risking everything I've ever worked
for right now that creates stress. Wow.
And how do you deal with that today?
Well, I don't gamble anymore that,
that she couldn't take it anymore.
It's just, it's just stupid.
There's no reason for me
to gamble when you have,
when you made as much money as me,
it's just retarded to gamble, right?
Because you can get caught up and lose
it all. What's the point? You know?
And it can happen,
right? People, of course,
especially when you go to
Macau and they're like,
do you want to fucking bet
bet with million dollar chips,
it makes me so nervous. It makes your day
can shrivel up into your body, you know,
pass by those tables in Vegas.
And I see someone who's willing to bet
like $25,000 on a roll of roulette. Right?
I've seen it happen. Oh No, that
was me. Oh, what a crazy move.
That's the pink chips.
And I got to the point in Vegas where
they knew me and they would let me bet a
quarter of million white one $7
million one night in Vegas and he's,
he's lost as much as a million. You guys
should get together and make out. I mean,
that guy has made a shit ton of money
doing UFC. And so to get his dick hard,
he has to that like that, you
know his dick hard. That's a,
that is not going to sit oppression for
gamblers, isn't it? I mean his dick hard.
Yeah. What's he going to do? Sit
at a table and play $20 blackjack,
like nickel slots. What is it about
people that love, first of all,
use a lot of UFC takes place in Vegas,
right? Yeah. So He's there alone. Okay.
So that's,
the UFC office is in vague and if
he's an addict then he's dangerously,
you know, like that's a
horrible place to live. Yeah.
But he's getting away with it because
he's rich and it makes a lot of money.
Right. And he figures out how to do
it and he's good at it. We'll see.
You in Vegas that kept you off.
You know,
you can't bet like you can't bet
the way you doing in the cow.
Well that's one of the reasons
why we stopped being at the palms.
They cut back his uh, his limit cut back
his credit cause he was killing them.
Yeah. If you, if you
have a shit ton of money,
if you have a bank roll
and you know how to gamble,
you could fucking knock one of
those casinos out and you know it.
They'll fucking, yeah, it's a good
feeling. That's Hilarious, man.
It's so crazy and dangerous and wild.
The idea Penton,
how much fucking money I don't,
how did you think I got to that
point? Oh, I'm sure you know yet that,
don't get me wrong.
You bet with your life savings and when,
when till you get to the point
where you're like, oh, now I'm like,
those guys betting $25,000.
Well,
you're a smart guy and you
also know that there's some,
there's some ways as a gambler in quotes,
you can sort of minimize the risks and
it's by being very intelligent about what
you're doing, right? That's exactly what
I'm telling you about MMA fighter, right,
but with much more everlasting
repercussions because if you get broke,
you're a smart guy, you'll figure
out how to get money. Again, you,
you already know the drill,
you know how to get rich,
but I'm not trying to be like a,
like a professional fighter
with their long career.
I'm trying to have why I understand,
but I'll tell you what, you get a,
I could kill me. Tiago Alvarez and one
fight could change your fucking life,
right?
That motherfucker would change the
whole rest of your life with a couple of
knees. It's just you got to
make sure that if you're,
you're finding someone
that they're like you,
a guy who's not necessarily
a lifelong expert.
Maybe there's a little bit of martial
arts and you got to get good at protecting
yourself against strikes.
That's the big one because it
sounds like if you have a judo base,
you'd probably really good grappler.
Judo guys are notoriously strong
core strength, hard to take down.
I give it amazing bear hugs,
but the striking striking is a
totally different thing. I have no,
we'll set you up,
fake you out and drop off fucking bomb
on your noodle and you're not going to
like it. I have a weak chin.
I'll get knocked the fuck out.
One cin one knock right here. I'll out
do it man. Don't do it then. Trust me.
It's about a grappling match.
You could,
that could be some hardcore shit you
could learn Jujitsu weren't learning
Jujitsu.
Get into a school like train and train
for grappling match and the worst case
scenario is you get tapped out,
you get strangled, you tapped out.
You're all right. You get an arm bar,
you tap out and it'll be fucking crazy,
wild and fun,
but you don't have to worry about
the lasting effects of head trauma.
It's still as possibly and
potentially very dangerous,
but you'll minimize the risks
considerably when you take out striking.
We'll just tell people
if you want to fight,
that shit should be a solitary thing.
There should be nothing else
you want to do in your life.
I don't want to fight and be a
bestselling author and be a fighter pilot.
It's what do you want to do?
Do you want to fight? Okay. No,
this dude's out there
that only want to find.
I decided that this is something
I'm going to do. I'm not going to,
I'm told anything else. I'll train
and that'll be it. That'll be my life.
Should do painting two you'd be
like me and multiple Musashi.
He was a Great Samurai who also did
a lot of calligraphy and painting.
He thought it was important.
Write poetry. I mean,
I mean the way I throw myself into
when I paint, that's all I do.
Throw my shit like I'm
like, this is, you know,
there's always going to be someone better
than me, but as far as I'm concerned,
I'm going to do the best I can and there's
nothing besides painting that's going
to obsess.
We had a cool conversation about work,
like last time I was at your place,
you know you go through
like these like spurts.
Sometimes we just decide to just attack
and just start working. But yeah,
I do that but also the same,
same way like you know when
people are like I'm an artist.
I'm like this is what I do.
Like even though I haven't painted like
for four years I do something creative
every day and if I had to
paint for a career like living,
then I don't do the gay. Like, oh,
I only paint when I'm emotionally like
move to do it. Or when I feel like it,
like whether I feel like shit, like
it's a real job. I show up every day,
every everyday repetition.
Paint a horse painted a thousand times,
it'll get better.
It's like it's a real job.
I paint whether my girlfriend dumped
me or whether she's sucking my dick or
whatever. Every fucking day you
paint, no matter what. No excuse.
That's a beautiful statement right there
and the people should take that and
make a video. I don't
be fucking gates. Just
the gay as in like, I don't, I don't
feel like I know what you're saying.
I need inspiration. Fuck
your inspirations. You
shouldn't call it gay. Okay.
You Force yourself, you force yourself
transgender. Don't call it that either.
Dick.
Um,
well gay as in Glorious and amazing
and yeah,
I know what you're saying. I know
what you're saying. It's um, I, I've,
I feel where you're coming from. You're
like, you're, it's a call to arms.
Get up and work. Get your shit
done. If you're a professional,
you do it every day and that's how the
work gets done. And don't be a wimp.
Don't be a pussy. Don't be weak. Don't be
a pussy. Shouldn't say, don't be a pussy.
[inaudible] amazing. It's
one of my favorite things.
Yeah, but don't say Ethiopia.
Why would you would be something amazing?
That'd be something I'd want to lick and
lick my stuff all day. It's not, it's,
it's just, it seems wrong to call
someone a pussy and that means it's,
he's a bad thing. I'm not trying to change
the language here. All right. It works.
It's better than fag.
But when they say don't be a pussy or
are they talking about like a pussy cat,
like a cat, is that worth
talking about? I don't know.
I mean the fat fuck Garfield Lasagna
and Cock sucker gave me irritable bowel
syndrome, but it's like for,
for success and shit like that.
Like especially with music or art
or something creative, it's like,
it's easy to be like,
I only feel inspired.
It's like fuck that repetition
putting in the time,
put it in, put in the time like, yeah,
force yourself whether you feel like
it or not. And you know, that's,
that's the way you do it. You're dead
right. You're dead right. That training,
it's training. It applies to
comedy, applies to martial arts.
This applies to everything.
And that's why when I paint
something like in two seconds, it's,
cause I've already painted it
a thousand times, you know, so
I don't want to be a Dick Joe,
but I have to actually run back to
silver other set up and I have to get,
uh, a painting done. Dude, I'm
broke out of time anyway. There was,
there's a lot of fun, man.
You were fired up today, dude,
you could tell you've been doing a lot
of podcasts. You're a different person.
Am I get a lot of shit to say now you're
an animal man. When you get comfortable,
you get wound up and you just fucking
fire off. Is this show over? Show's over.
Show is, um, it is right now. A six, 12.
Does it do just end it whenever
you feel like it ended?
Whenever I feel like we don't
have any producers plan.
I got to beat traffic and feet.
That traffic son.
I'm going to bribe a are a Brie plaza
into being my best friend. Who's that?
She's the actress from doing shout
outs right now. No, no, no, no.
Given someone a shout. Oh,
I got to go. How dare you.
She wants a painting for me and I said,
it's for you to get a painting for me.
You gotta be my best.
Thanks to stamps.com use the code word
jre on stamps.com and save some money.
Thanks to onnit.com use the code word
Rogan and save 10% off any and all
supplements. All right. You freaks. Uh,
we'll see you next week. Yeah, yeah,
absolutely. Everyone, thanks
for listening to Joe Rogan show.
If you like this shit, oh,
this is my first commercial.
I got a show called double
vege, double anal sensitive
artist. That's DVD, asa.com.
Go listen to it. That's my show. Um,
if you guys the asa and if you guys
like the early episodes with Yoshi,
he has his own show called Yoshi.
Didn't go listen to that show
and that's all I got to pause.
Take care.com and also the cure.
My Beautiful Costar,
beautiful party people will
see you guys next week.
Everybody have a good time this weekend.
Oh, will be Friday night. We'll be at the,
uh,
the ice house fucking around in that
little room if you've ever been to the ice
house is that little tiny room there and
uh, I'll be there. Brian, who's where,
who else was there? Oh yeah.
Faheem uh, Justin Martindale, uh,
got a couple other people that places
the lab that places where we do our best
fucking around to come up with
new material. It's a really small,
it's only like 80 people and it's
a lot of fun. All right, so, uh,
that's the ice house Friday
night. And, uh, all right,
one last plug. Beautiful Viva.
Yeah. Good date. November 2nd,
November 2nd. I don't know
what I'm going to do that,
but it's going to be,
that's the year. Last year,
November 2nd I took over the reddit.
I'm going to maybe do something
weird like that again,
so just don't know what I'm gonna do that
you're giving out. Pay attention to me.
November, December 2nd. Picture her. Write
something crazy, right. Party people.
Thanks everybody. Love
you. I'll see you soon.
Bye.
Yeah.